(gentle music)
The simple thing that we do every day, consume foods,
can have such a huge impact that we don't even realize.
(upbeat music)
Our choices impact the future.
People realizing that their voice is valuable and important.
(upbeat music)
Greetings, everyone.
Prepare myself for today's podcast
because this one wades into the waters of veganism,
which is a topic I care a great deal about, obviously,
nonetheless, it's one that I recognize
can be in an emotive subject for many
and a divisive, maybe even treacherous topic for others.
But fear not today's waters are warm.
Thanks to my esteemed guest, Ed Winters,
who is an educator, a public speaker, a content creator,
an author and vegan advocate.
Most known as Earthling Ed on the internet.
And although Ed is only 27,
he's quickly become one of the most compelling
and powerful voices in the vegan movement.
A millennial Peter singer, if you will,
who, in addition to accumulating bazillions of views
here on YouTube, has lectured at many UK universities,
including Cambridge.
He served as a guest lecturer at Harvard.
He spoken at several Ivy league institutions
and major corporations
like Google, Facebook, and The Economist,
and has appeared in many mainstream media outlets
like the BBC.
The occasion for today's conversation
is Ed's tremendous new, all things vegan book entitled,
"This Is Vegan Propaganda:
And Other Lies the Meat Industry Tells You"
which is, let's face it just an incredible title
vested only by the content there in.
So today we talk, obviously all things V-E-G-A-N,
including the moral philosophy that underpins it.
Ed's rebuttals to the many common arguments
against veganism,
the powerful ways in which cultural forces
drive cognitive dissonance
around our food and consumer choices,
the ethical and environmental implications
of those decisions,
how to be an effective advocate, very important,
and many other topics.
So if you find yourself vegan curious
but haven't yet found the will to commit,
I suspect Ed just might be the catalyst
you've been waiting for.
We cover a lot today,
but there's so much more to Ed and his message.
So if you find yourself eager
to continue your investigation,
I encourage you to not only pick up Ed's new book,
this is vegan propaganda,
but to also spend time on his YouTube channel,
which is linked in the description below,
because it's all their people, all of it is there.
I think that's enough for me,
so please hit that subscribe button
and without further ado, I give you Ed Winters,
AKA Earthling Ed.
Its so nice to meet you.
I've been wanting to meet you for a very long time.
It's somewhat surprising
that we haven't crossed paths in person.
But I've been following your work for quite some time
and always knew that I wanted to have you here.
And we're in the perfect moment to have you here
because you have this amazing new book coming out,
"This Is Vegan Propaganda"
which is a title for the ages.
Like this is made for the internet.
Like it's so cheeky and obviously contemplates
the fact that the first thing that a naysayer might say
is that this book is vegan propaganda.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
That was the idea behind it.
When we were kind of coming up with the title for the book,
we went through so many different iterations for it
and we kind of landed on this idea of propaganda.
'Cause I'd made a video
and I'd used the word vegan propaganda
as kind of like a thing that people say
about the information.
And we were like, let's run with that.
There's something there,
so like we messed around of it a little bit.
And we are like this vegan propaganda's a good
kind of tongue in cheek, disarming of that phrase
that we kind of hear often as vegans.
I think it's perfect.
Oh good.
I love it.
In thinking about you and your advocacy
and the way you sort of comport yourself in the world
and carry this message that you care about so deeply,
I think that what is so indelibly powerful
about you specifically, is this very intentional,
elegant style of communication that you have,
and this level of like patience and unflappable, equanimity,
like equanimity really is like the touchdown
and how you kind of interact with people.
When you talk about veganism
and address the Pantheon of arguments
that get hurled in your direction
as a defender of this way of life.
And in that there are so many different aspects
of the vegan lifestyle.
There's health, there's in the environment sustainability,
there's compassion, all of that.
But your primary animating force
is really rooted in ethics and moral responsibility.
So I think a good place to start
is just to unpack that a little bit
and kind of how you got into this to begin with.
The way that I see veganism is that it is a moral issue.
I often say to people like,
even if eating animal products
was just as bad for the environment,
or the exact same for the environment
and had no negative repercussions on your health
and it was exactly the same both ways, even though it isn't,
but even if it was that case,
there's still a moral reason to be vegan, the animals.
And so for me, I've always come at it from that moral angle
and I think that the other arguments
really supplement and solidify that reason to be vegan
in a way that kind of makes it undeniably,
the right thing to do.
But that moral framework
has always been really important to me
and it was the decision,
or that was the kind of thing that led me to the decision
to change myself.
And I went vegan in 2015
and had been vegetarian for about eight months before them.
And the reason I went vegetarian
is because I came across this story
about a truck carrying around 6 1/2 thousand chickens
crashing on the way to a slaughterhouse near Manchester,
which is a city in Northern England.
And I was reading this story
and just feeling so dreadfully, sorry for these chickens,
the journalist was describing how many of them had died,
there were more who were alive,
but they were on the side of the road. They were mutilated.
They had broken bones, broken wings.
And I realized that they could suffer,
which is such a strange thing to realize,
'cause obviously the animals who we farm can suffer,
but how often do we ever stop and think about that?
I never had.
And so I was thinking about these chickens
who were suffering and then I realized,
well, hang on a minute.
It's not this the chickens on the side of the road,
the destination they were heading to is hardly much better,
potentially even worse than for many of the chickens
because of what they endure in these slaughterhouses.
So I felt like a hypocrite because in my fridge was a KFC
and I used to love fried chicken.
It was like my favorite food.
I had a KFC outlet
that was about maybe a five, 10 minute walk
from where I used to live in London.
And I went there so often
that I became very accustomed to the workers
and they knew who I was,
and we had this kind of like rapport going
and it was just this kind of biweekly, twice weekly
kind of pilgrimage that I went on to get my fried chicken.
But anyway, my fridge was some leftover fried chicken,
but now I'm empathizing with chickens
in a way I never have before.
And I thought, hang on a minute,
what are my values when it comes to animals?
And one thing I often ask people is,
are you against animal cruelty?
And we all say that we are,
and people who commit cruel acts to animals
are seen as some of the worst people that can exist.
And we really look down upon violence towards pets
like dogs and cats and, and such
but we turn a blind eye to the cruelty
that's inflicted on farm animals
and indeed animals that are exploited in other ways as well.
So when I ask people, are you against animal cruelty?
What I'm trying to do, I suppose,
is highlight that contradiction our values.
When we say about cruelty and I say to people,
can you define what that means to be cruel to someone?
People will always say that it's about causing physical
or mental emotional harm.
It's about doing something that unnecessary,
that negatively contributes to someone else's wellbeing.
And then when we think about what we do to animals,
of course, it's cruel.
We mutilate them, we exploit them,
we forcibly impregnate them.
We take their babies away from them.
And then we take their life from them prematurely
for an unnecessary reason.
I mean, to me, that's like the definition of being cruel
to an animal.
So I realize that in that moment, thinking about the KFC,
thinking about the chickens
and realizing that there was this kind of disalignment
in the person I thought I was when it came to animals
and the person I actually was.
And so I kind of reached this fork in the road,
if your part in the (indistinct), but this fork in the road
where I could choose to kind of bury my head in the sands,
kind of hopefully repress those feelings
and just get on with my life
and not worry about animals anymore,
or I could accept this something not quite right
with my values and my actions.
And I chose the latter and went vegetarian
'cause I didn't know anything about dairy or eggs.
And then I saw "Earthlings",
which is a documentary that exposes
what happens in Us farms and slaughterhouses.
The movie we all begrudgingly watch.
Exactly.
We have to get dragged
to watching it and then we're never the same.
It is a hard watch, isn't it?
it's like an hour and 40 minutes of objective,
I guess, undercover, hidden camera footage
that just shows what happens to animal.
And after that, I went and spent time
with Ruper, the hamster who was my first real pet.
And I don't like to use the word pet so much,
but more like companion animal.
He was kind of my companion.
And I had Ruper in my hands
and I was looking at Ruper, the hamster
and I gave him some broccoli
'cause broccoli was his favorite food.
He loved broccoli, absolutely loved it.
So I gave him and broccoli and I was looking at Ruper,
eating this broccoli with his cute little paws.
He always looked so adorable.
And I was looking at him thinking
there's so much about Ruper
that creates a moral worth for him.
He's an individual,
he has likes and dislikes and he loved the broccoli,
but he didn't like other things like kale, for example.
He had likes and dislikes
things that made him Ruper, the hamster
and I up all the animals who were exploited
in all the different ways that we exploit them.
I wasn't eating meat,
but I was still consuming dairy and eggs.
I was still perpetuating systems
that exploits animals in other means.
And it really dawned on meat in that moment
that the issue of what we do to animals
isn't just really about food,
Food is a symptom of the problem.
The problem is mentality that creates the justification
for these systems to exist in the first place.
The fact that we view non-human animals
or these non-human animals with such little worth,
that we can then justify
doing everything that we do to them.
That's the problem.
And I realize that veganism
isn't just about eating plant-based food,
it's about challenging that mindset,
that value use non human animals as having such little worth
that we can do these unspeakably cruel things to them
and not bat an eyed about I most of the time.
A lot of people have an analogous experience
where they're witness to some type of animal cruelty
and they're compelled to kind of reckon
with how that measures up against their value system.
But not that many people use that as a lever
or a tipping point to actually make change.
I mean, there's so much packed into that.
There's the level of cognitive dissonance,
this idea like, we all flinch and look away from things
like "Earthlings" and slaughterhouse videos
and stuff like that for the very reason.
And you talk about this,
like the very reason that it will compel us to confront
that dissonance.
And if we do that,
then perhaps we either need to make that change
that we don't wanna make,
or we have to live with that level of disconnect,
which creates kind of like
just a lack of integration with just being human.
So you had this moment.
What was it about your background or leading up to that,
that you were kind of primed to make that change
that so many struggle to make?
Well, I think that we often as vegans,
we often think of this one moment,
I saw "Earthlings" that made me vegan,
but what we forget or don't often realize
is that throughout our whole life,
there are all these little moments
that are building up to this, this kind of realization.
And so throughout my whole life,
I was raised with this mentality
that animals should be cared for.
That people that do bad things to animals are wrong.
That we should try and protect our environment.
I was raised with these values.
And I was raised with the,
I guess the concept
that a world we've reduced suffering is preferable.
So this was kinda like the mentality I had,
but I'd never really connected all of these components
wit being vegan or with the consequence of not being vegan.
So for me, it was just like this, I suppose,
domino effect of thinking about
these different points in my life.
For example, I stopped going to zoos
before I stopped eating meats and dairy and eggs.
And the reason I stopped going to zoos
is because I had seen the documentary "Blackfish"
and the documentary "Blackfish"
made me not want to go to aquariums.
But then I went to Barcelona zoo and in Barcelona zoo,
I saw a bear and this bear just looked so solemn and so sad.
That it would just sat down
in this very small enclosure looking around.
And I kind of followed their eyes,
they looked around the enclosure
and looked at the four walls they were trapped in.
And it dawned on me that these animals
are also being kept in captivity
like the Orca at sea world are.
So I left Barcelona Zoo
and never went to another zoo after that.
So I had these kind of moments
that made me realize that what we're doing to animals,
isn't something that's good for animals.
It's definitely not.
But also is something that contradicts kind of the values
that I have towards how we should treat them.
And really just this last piece of the puzzle
was just being, kind of confronted if you like,
with the objective reality
of this is what you are paying for
when you go into the supermarket and you buy this.
We may view these decisions as being unconscious
because they are unconscious,
but they have this very real, tangible consequence
that we often don't think about.
And so I was forced to go,
when I go into a supermarket
and I go into a restaurant or wherever it is,
and I give my money to these industries,
I am personally funding these very things
that I'm feeling and very upset about to continue.
And how do I, as a person who wants to reduce suffering,
who thinks that a world that,
obviously we're never gonna create a utopia,
but a world that is trying to reach that utopia
as much as we can,
how does paying for slaughterhouses to exist,
how does that work and this kind of vision of the future
that I would like to live in?
It doesn't.
So it was all these little moments,
but then, just this overarching realization
that I'm not living in alignment,
that I'm fundamentally a hypocrite
when it comes to my treatment of animals.
And that was the final piece to go.
There is a problem here
that is bigger than just this food problem.
It's a mentality issue. And there's a consequence of that.
I have to be that example of what I want to see.
So where does the transition
from simply living this lifestyle turn into,
this is my life's work.
That's a big leap, right?
Yeah, it is.
I had been vegan for a little while,
and my partner she had been watching some YouTubers
and we'd been watching,
absorbing a lot of information about veganism.
I'd learned about the environmental stuff,
I'd learned about the health impact,
about individual chronic health,
but also kind of a global
infectious disease risk problem as well.
Antibiotic resistance, all these things.
I'd learned about the true scale of the problem
and how just this simple thing
that we do every day, consume foods,
can have such a huge impact
that we don't even realize.
Like it's one of the most important decisions
that we make every day for ourselves,
but also for the health of the planet.
And every single being that coexist here with us.
It can feel, I suppose,
kind of maybe a little bit of exaggerated
to make such a claim, but our choices impact the future,
impacts us in every single way
that we can possibly think of in that sense.
So when I started to realize the enormity
and scale of the problem,
I kind of felt that I needed to do something about it,
that simply just living this way, myself, wasn't enough with
because I'm still kind of allowing
these actions to continue.
And before I was vegan, I kind of didn't know.
And I think about how I've reacted
if someone had given me this information.
Would I have changed earlier?
Would I have had that realization before?
And I think about all the people in the world
who align with the same values I have
and who would probably make that change like I did,
if they kind of realized the same things that I realized.
And so being silent in the face of adversity
is still allowing that adversity to continue.
Is still a form of complicity
because you are being a bystander to that exploitation
and damage continue to happen.
So I realized I needed to speak up in some way,
and that started off by just being,
uploading YouTube videos.
And the first ones I did were it's very rough
and I was super nervous,
but I felt that it was important
to try and communicate this message
because so many people
just have never heard about it before.
At least have heard about it,
but have never really sat
and thought about the reasons to be vegan.
So it was really YouTube from the get go for you.
Pretty much.
You are a true millennial.
Yeah, I guess so, I tick that box.
Did you study philosophy, or argumentation, or discourse?
Like you have such a facility with language,
and like I said earlier,
just this composure about you that feels very crafted
and skilled.
Like where did you learn how to do that?
I mean, it was really trial and error.
It's very kind of you to say,
but there was no real kind of education that I went under.
I studied film and TV at university
and I had this aspiration of being some big movie director,
but quickly realized that that's not what I wanted to do,
but I could have those transferrable skills
and apply it to being a YouTuber, of course.
But for me it was just a process of trial and error,
I kind of had these conversations with people in the street,
just very rough conversations at the beginning
where I'd go out to places like
Leicester Square or Trafalgar Square in London
and try to strike up conversations
with members of the public
and ask some, hopefully prompting questions.
But I quickly realized what worked and what didn't work.
And I quickly realized that having
an aggressive tone or using certain language,
or kind of putting someone in a defensive mode,
doesn't help people reach positive conclusion.
And I had conversations with people
where I overstepped the mark a little bit
where I maybe was a little bit too,
or at least I came across a bit judgemental,
I came across, like I had this, air of superiority.
And I thought, well, who am I doing this for?
Because being an advocate,
you are trying to represent something
and being an advocate for this movement
means I'm trying to represent something or someone
who isn't me the animals whose voices we ignore
because their screams are behind walls of slaughterhouses.
So if I'm trying to be an advocate for them,
then I can't allow this kind of self-serving
philosophy of wanting to make myself feel good
by allowing these emotions to overtake me,
this kind anger or this frustration,
that's self-serving.
But if I'm trying to be an advocate
for them or someone else,
I just think about their best interests
and I quickly realize that
allowing these kind of self-serving emotions,
wasn't productive.
Trying to be this,
I suppose, almost voice of someone's conscience.
when I'm in these conversations,
I'm trying to not impose my myself,
but really just allow someone else
to understand themselves better, themself,
trying to allow them to understand
how they view these situations.
What attitudes do they have?
And so, I try and revolve these conversations
around asking questions
and trying to get people to understand their own beliefs
rather than telling them what my beliefs are.
Well, you're very effective in that.
And I wanna put a pin in that,
I wanna come back to effective advocacy
in the later stages of this conversation,
'cause I think that's super important and interesting.
But on the thread of sort of advocating
on behalf of vegan lifestyle,
I feel like the Overton window has really expanded,
like even in the last couple years,
like this is now part of the mainstream discourse,
people are not confused about what it means so much,
people are interested in and intrigued by it.
So I wanna kind of establish the moral landscape here
and then expand upon that too,
for you to just kind of advocate on behalf of this,
in your own words,
like why should somebody go vegan?
I mean, you do these, you go around to colleges
and I wanna talk about how you set up these booths,
like Lucy in "Peanuts" and say,
everybody should go vegan, prove me wrong and all of that.
So you've had hundreds,
if not thousands of these interactions,
but if somebody came to you and just said,
"Ed, tell me why I should be vegan?"
Like how do you respond to that?
I think it comes down to a number of factors.
But the first thing to acknowledge is that we can be vegan.
What sets apart our current time
from to times in the past
is the fact that we have that option
in a way that previous generations didn't
throughout history.
So the first thing to acknowledge is that it's a choice.
And once we recognize it's a choice,
it then becomes a moral issue.
Obviously what we do to animals is a moral issue
because we all think that animals deserve
some form of moral consideration.
That's why we say animal cruelty is wrong.
And we even talk about animal welfare
because we have an understanding
that we want to reduce suffering.
So we recognize that what we do to animals is a moral issue.
And then we recognize that what we do to animals
is a choice and is it something that we have to do?
So then we have to look
at why we think animals deserve moral consideration.
And I always think about it from my own perspective
as a human first.
And I recognize it as a human,
and because I have things, sentience, individuality,
the capacity to feel whether that's pleasure or pain,
happiness, or suffering,
that I have an awareness of my surroundings,
basically that I have this sentience,
that, that assigns me moral worth
because when someone harms me, it's causing me suffering.
When someone does something to impede on my life,
that's impeding on my life.
And that's kind of broadly why we recognize
that arbitrarily harming other humans
based on superfluous reasons,
such as sexuality or ethnicity or whatever it may be,
sadly enough.
We recognize that's obviously wrong
because these people as sentient individuals
who have these capacities
in much the same way that we all do, of course.
So if I'm assigning moral,
worked myself based on these characteristics and traits,
I have to work out whether or not the non-human animals
also tick these boxes.
Our pigs, chickens, cows, marine animals,
are they sentient?
Are they conscious?
Do they have the capacity to suffer?
Feel pain, also pleasure, happiness, perhaps as well.
And we know that they do.
We recognize that with the animals we have in our homes.
That dogs and have these personalities,
things that make them fluffy, the cat
or in a box or the dog,
whatever name we might assign to these animals.
We recognize this about them
and we know that they have this broad spectrum of emotions.
And we know that with the animals who we farm
and who we exploit as well.
And so when I think about them as individuals,
I have to think about what moral justification do I have
to arbitrarily harm them and unnecessarily kill them.
And you can't morally justify that,
in the current context of a modern day society.
So it's about recognizing that these animals
from a moral perspective should have worth the transcends
the reasons we use to exploit them,
taste, food, nutrition.
We know we can get nutrition
from plant-based sources instead.
So when we recognize it's unnecessary
and we recognize that these animals have these capacities,
that becomes what I would describe as a,
it becomes a moral obligation to be vegan
because it's the best way to reduce suffering
to its fullest extent
when it comes to our treatment of animals.
And we're all against animal suffering,
all against animal cruelty.
So it's about working out how we apply that logic
the most consistently
and farming them in any way
or taking them to a slaughterhouse to kill them,
which is what happens to every farmed animal.
Even if they're raised for dairy and eggs,
they still meet the same miserable end prematurely,
that can't be changed while we still farm them.
And that causes suffering and cruelties.
So the best way to extend that, to it's first extent
is by no longer paying for these things to happen to them
in the first place.
There's so much cognitive dissonance that comes into play.
And there's this leap to really embracing
the individuation of these animals.
And I feel like society is structured
to entrench that cognitive dissonance
and prevent us from empathizing
with the individualistic nature of these animals.
We all know with our pets,
we can see that and we understand that,
but then this wall comes down when it comes to other species
particularly farmed animals for our food
where we're not so quick to make that leap.
The psychological aspect of it to me
is almost more interesting than the intellectual arguments.
It's like you can make those intellectual arguments
and we all get it,
but there's a gap between that understanding
and behavior change
that lies in this very murky terrain
around how the human animal operates.
It's so important,
and what you said that I think is really profound
because it's really easy, I suppose, in principle,
to get people to understand
the reasons why change is important.
But as you say, there are these barriers,
social, psychological, emotional
that can restrict us from making those rational choices.
I mean, the third section of the book
is really trying to address that.
And I think we have to understand the mechanisms
behind why we have this attitude.
And broadly speaking,
we categorize animals into free kind of groups.
We have wild animals, we have pets
and then we have farm animals.
And by categorizing animals in that way,
it allows us to treat them differently
based on the categorization we've given them.
So in a sense, what we do is we otherized farm animals
and we've othrized humans throughout history
to then provide a justification
for causing unnecessary harm.
And that's what we do with farm animals,
we've otherized them.
And so we kind of view them as being abstractions.
we have pets in our home
and we assign them individual personalities,
but pigs and chickens,
while they're just this abstract concept.
Pigs are dirty, chickens are stupid.
So by kind of assigning just this one characteristic
or these broad characteristics to an entire species,
it makes what we do to the more palatable,
because we're not viewing them as individuals.
And I think part of the problem
with the scale of animal agriculture
is it allows us to detach
from that right individuality of each animal.
Even when I'm advocating,
I'm quite conscious to make the point of,
whilst it's terrible that we farm 80 billion land animals
and we kill somewhere
between 0.8 and 2.3 trillion marine animals
every single year,
whilst that is obviously terrible 'cause of the numbers,
what's important is that those numbers
are made up of individuals, solitary individual animals
who are experiencing everything themselves.
So I think because we've otherized animals
and we've created to these abstract concepts
of what these species that we farm represent.
It then allows us to not have to really engage
with the actions that we're committing.
It's similar to our difficulty
in empathizing with a genocide
versus the one kid who's stuck in the well.
Exactly. That's exactly right, isn't it?
So I think that part of this problem
is the detachment from the process.
Where we live and the cultures where we currently are,
there is this huge detachment from the slaughterhouse,
the farm and the supermarkets. And I think in the US,
there was a study in schools
that said that a lot of school children think
that chocolate milk comes from brown cows.
There's this huge disconnection
from what we're paying for on what we're consuming.
And so there is this element
of having to become more conscious as consumers.
To intellectually recognize the reasons to make the change,
but then challenge some of those barriers
that exist in that cognitive dissonance.
The confirmation bias that we can all grapple with at times.
We have to be kind of mindful and conscious
of these external factors that influence our behavior.
Because by being mindful of those external factors,
we can then try and work out
whether or not our actions are aligning
with our rational thought processes.
And I think it's just as simple sometimes
as going to a supermarket,
looking at the foods we normally buy
and just taking a moment to pause.
Just thinking about who is this from?
Who did this used to belong to?
By meat, this is a piece of flesh,
so where did that come from?
And just trying to take a moment
to be more thoughtful and our decision making
can help us sometimes see through those
unconscious barriers that can drive our behaviors.
It's so fascinating.
I think you say in the book, you cite these to statistics.
People are poll about their relationship
with factory farming.
Most people say it should be abolished
or we shouldn't have it,
but 99% of those people the next day
go to the supermarket and just pick up whatever.
So, it's so weird that we're that way
or that we understand that pigs are as smart as dogs,
if not smarter, probably smarter,
right?
Sure.
That they have personalities, et cetera, and yet bacon.
Like people just can't get around it.
We're gonna get into all the various arguments
that you field,
but on the subject of continuing down this path
of just making the case for veganism.
It becomes harder and harder to defend our habits,
the more educated we are.
And that's really kind of the tip of your sphere,
like prioritizing education,
but being in a place of allowing people
to make their own decisions around it.
Absolutely.
We as a species are of course ignorance about so many things
and ignorance, isn't a bad thing
because we can't ever know everything,
but at the same time,
the antidote of ignorance is education.
So there can be, I suppose,
this belief that non-vegans have
that vegan can be judgemental have an air of superiority.
I'm sure some vegans do tick those boxes.
but by and large, I think that what the role
of a vegan advocate is really just to try
and give some to provide some education
to someone who just has never heard of these arguments.
I think what we have to understand
is that good people do bad things.
We're all guilty of that
We all live in some level
of moral ambiguity.
Absolutely.
'Cause we can never be morally puritanical, can we?
And so I think we have to recognize
that good people can do bad things
and that these bad things
are driven by often external factors, such as advertising,
such as a detachment from the reality
of what we're purchasing.
Such as this proliferation of information
and industry funded studies
that creates doubt in the eyes of the consumer.
There are so many things
that lead us to making the decisions that we make.
And I think just having that recognition
that we are all capable of doing bad things
but at the same time we're all capable of doing better.
And education can be an antidote to that ignorance.
Aristotle, I see in the books, says that,
the roots of education are bitter, but the fruit is sweet.
Obviously what we do to animals
is a deeply uncomfortable topic.
And I suppose that the broader consequence
of the environmental damage,
the personal health consequences,
these things that are terrifying and frightening,
and it's often very to learn something
that contradicts the way that we've lived our entire life.
But the consequence of that,
the fruit of that is something so important,
which is that we're creating a better food system,
which is a consequence of that improves
so many of these issues
that we're currently facing as a species.
Are you able to maintain hopefulness amid all of this,
or you find yourself descending into cynicism?
It can really vary.
Some days I can feel cynical,
some days I feel probably overly optimistic.
But I think by and large, I have a huge amount of faith,
whether that's misguided, I'm not sure,
but I think humans are an incredible species
because we are obviously so intellectual,
we're obviously capable of doing so much.
And whilst we are deeply flawed in so many ways,
we're also capable of achieving something better.
And I think one of the reasons
why I enjoy having these conversations
and going to college campuses and such
is because it allows me to connect with people
I would never normally connect with,
cowboys, farmers.
People have very different views to me,
but it allows me to sit down
and talk with them for 30 minutes, 40 minutes,
and really get to know them and understand how they feel.
And I often leave these conversations
feeling very optimistic
because I recognize that deep down
we all want the same thing,
which is a better world fundamentally.
We might have differing views on how we get there,
but we all have this idea that we want,
when it comes to agriculture, at least,
that we want a more sustainable system,
a more ethical system, a more just system,
a system that reduces disparity
for people in low economic scenarios.
We all want to strive for that.
It's just, we haven't quite reached
the commonality of how to get there.
But these conversations I have with people,
they reassure me that when we sit down
and talk about these issues,
and these are big moral concerns,
and these are big philosophical topics,
just a conversation can really help us reach
an era of commonality,
which leaves me feeling a lot more empowered
than I probably without that aspect of my advocacy.
So you've lectured and taught at many colleges,
you've traveled all over the place,
you were a guest lecturer at Harvard,
which is super interesting.
I think you're doing an online thing with Harvard.
Yes.
Like next week,
which is cool.
But in addition to that, like I mentioned earlier,
you set up these booths on college campuses
and you entertain these conversations with people
about veganism.
You share those clips on Instagram and on and on YouTube.
So you've had so many of these conversations
and every argument conceivable I'm sure
has been foisted upon you that you've had to field.
How many of those conversations end up
'cause you're only choosing which ones to share,
you're having many more of them.
Do you get the sense that you're moving the needle
or at least leaving people with something to think about?
I mean, that's my sense,
occasionally you'll have a frustrating one but overall,
my feeling is that young people
are engaging you in good faith
and they may have their head in a different place,
but there's a lot of kind of mutual respect
that goes both ways in these conversations.
And irrespective of the outcome, that gives me hope.
Like I think that's cool to just witness.
I mean, exactly right.
We tend to upload nearly all the conversations
that take place.
And I've just been traveling for the past few weeks.
I've got so much content because the thing about the US
is people are very open to telling you their views.
That's a loaded statement in and of itself.
It's a polite way of saying
there's a little bit of division that occurs here sometimes.
But people are very open to that
and that's part of the reason why I like being here.
And so I've had monster of these conversations,
but you are right by and large, which is that there is this,
I think respectful dialogue that hopefully takes place.
And I try very hard to facilitate that.
So when people sit down the camera operator
will start moving the cameras,
checking the memory cards, checking the batteries.
And we do that deliberately,
so that I have two or three minutes
just to sit and talk to of someone, not about veganism.
What do you study?
Where are you from?
Do you like it? Just really build up a bit of rapport
because if we're gonna engage in these conversations
where I'm gonna be challenging people fundamentally
on their lifestyle and their belief system,
we need to make sure
that we're going into that with this positive mindset.
So trying to just make someone feel comfortable immediately
is very important
because if we want people to be vulnerable,
we have to express vulnerability in ourselves.
We have to be able to,
I suppose, make statements that almost,
I guess what I'm trying to say is it's important for us
to be able to own up to things
that they're right to about as well.
And I think in a debate,
what can often happen is people have this reluctance
to accept that they're wrong,
or accept that the other person's made a good point.
It's always, no, I have to be 100% right
and nothing they say can be valid.
And I think just taking that moment at the beginning
to build with a rapport, lowers both of our defenses
to be open enough to be able to say,
that's a really good point that you've made,
or I understand why you're saying,
or yeah, I've never thought about that before,
because we have this kind of almost very early friendship
emerging from just this moment of rapport building.
And I think having those kind of techniques
of just taking the time to listen to someone,
asking them thoughtful questions.
Trying to understand their argument.
There is this, I think fracturing
that's occurring within society
where we're kind of caricaturing people
and their beliefs
based on certain principles of their identity.
And we don't actually take the time
to understand people's beliefs anymore.
And I think why I like having these conversations
is I'm interested to understand
why people think the way they do,
how did they reach the, that conclusion?
Why do you think this is the way that it is?
Because it makes me better as an advocate as well?
How am I supposed to be,
I suppose, competent at debating people
if I don't understand what their point of view is.
So I think that builds respect as well.
Just listening and being genuinely interested
and sincere in your, I guess, your care of their beliefs.
And to that point point,
I assume it's intentional on your part
to purposefully attend colleges with animal husbandry
and animal agriculture departments
like Cornell and Texas A&M like those are,
like there's a lot of students
that I'm sure you interacted with
who are actually studying how to be animal agriculturalists
on some level.
And that I'm sure you're confronting
a lot of cognitive dissonance.
I mean, they're being, indoctrinated is the wrong word,
but they're being kind of trained and educated
in a particular way of life and profession
that is at odds with your core moral philosophy.
Yeah, that exact scenario played out
at Texas A&M recently,
this guy sat down this really proud Texan, from rural Texas,
told me he didn't like the cities,
he just liked being out in the middle of the wild west.
And he was studying animal ag, animal ag science.
And so he sat down very respectfully and was just like,
"I'm really interested to hear your point of view."
And I was like, "Well, that's great.
Now I'm interested to hear yours."
And so we started this conversation and he said,
"Well, I was told today in my class that dairy cows
like to be farmed, they queue up to be milked
and so it's a consensual thing."
And I said, well, that's a very interesting statement,
but it kind of misses the finer details,
which is that, we've selectively bred dairy cows
to produce excessive amounts of milk.
Dairy cows need to be milked because they're producing milk
and it's uncomfortable for them not to be milked.
So there's a reason why dairy cows
will walk themselves into the milking parlor,
it's because they have to be milked.
why is it causes them pain, mastitis, all of these things,
but it doesn't make them
willing participants in their exploitation,
just because they go through this
predetermined biological process
where they have to have their milk released
should be done by their child, of course,
but in the absence of their child
must be done through the machinery.
Just because they willfully walk into that environment,
doesn't make everything else we do to them consensual.
But so there is that indoctrination
that exists within these courses
because farmers by and large
are raised in farming communities.
And this is a really important thing to recognize.
And they're raised with a belief system
that's given to them
by their parents and their grandparents.
These are family farms passed down generation to generation.
And as a child growing up in that environment,
seeing what the farm means to your family
and feeling the expectation
that you have to go into that farming scenario yourself,
plus you're in a community
that's just farmers and farming families,
so your friends are farmers
and you grew up with farming children,
it's all you've ever known.
So what choice do you have but to pursue that?
I think it requires an exceptional amount
of humility and dedication for a child to break out of that.
So then they go to universities, colleges
that are studying teaching animal ag science.
So they come from farming communities with farming families,
go learn about farming and then become farmers.
And it's all they've ever known.
I think it's easy to understand why many farmers
may not sit down like that Texan did
and have a conversation with me,
why they may feel threatened by the presence of someone
who's out outspoken about their veganism,
because it's not just challenging their livelihood,
it's challenging their entire existence, their identity.
Yeah, completely.
Like I can easily empathize with the level of defensiveness
or resistance
that somebody in that position have towards you.
Absolutely.
With your long hair,
it's like, come on, dude.
The opposite of a Texan cowboy.
What do you know about my life?
Yeah, exactly.
So how does that go?
Like how did it play out with that guy?
Really well.
I was lucky in the sense
that he was very receptive and open minded
and he didn't leave with this revelation
that he was gonna stop studying animal science
and become vegan.
That didn't happen.
But at the same time he left, I would hope,
with an understanding about veganism,
but also an understanding about vegans
that he didn't have before.
I think that vegans often have an optics problem,
that we have this perception of us
which is really damaging,
and a lot of the time
we don't necessarily help ourselves with that perception,
I can be the first one to (indistinct) that.
It's incredibly emotive and divisive, as you have said,
regardless of whether you're pro or con.
Just saying the word,
people get agitated no matter what.
So first of all, what does it even mean?
Why does that word tend to provoke people
one way or the other.
And you're correct,
vegans can be their own worst enemies
and there's a lot of infighting and confusion
amidst the community that is not helpful.
No.
So I think optics are a massive part of that problem
and I think very quickly I realized that being a messenger
isn't necessarily so much about what you say
but how you say it, how you come across.
And with that cowboy,
and hopefully with most people that sit down
and talk to me or engage with me in one way or another,
I just want them to leave with the feeling that,
oh, okay vegans can be this way.
Vegans can listen, vegans can be respectful,
vegans can engage in a thoughtful manner.
They're gonna call me an animal murder
as soon as I sit down.
And I think that that's an important aspect
of what I try and do,
is just trying to, I suppose, reframe people's perceptions
of what bean vegan means.
'Cause it's easy for us to distance ourself
from doing something
if we don't like the person who's doing it.
So, if we can't disagree with the message
that causing unnecessary suffering to animals is wrong,
the next best thing
is to disagree with the person saying it.
And so people are looking for any excuse
to I suppose disbar from these conversations,
to not have to engage.
And if we, as vegans perpetuating a stereotype
that people don't want to engage with,
then that's how they distance themselves
from these really important issues.
So the first thing we have to do is be,
I suppose, personable and approachable
as that people will then want to listen.
And if we fail that first hurdle and we don't come across-
The game's over.
Yeah, it's over just like that.
And not only that,
you have to overcome all of these other barriers and hurdles
because the media is hard at work at characterizing,
there's a whole thing in the book about this,
and you've made videos about this,
the mischaracterization on behalf of the media
to paint a broad picture of vegans and veganism,
as insane militants and violent people
who wanna kill babies, et cetera, all of that kind of stuff.
So people come in with their preconceived idea
that you have to rebut.
So you almost have to be all the much more
sort of patient and conciliatory.
And it's hard at times,
but you're right there is often,
maybe a concerted effort is a little bit too dramatic,
but there is often an abundance of media articles
and press releases that are staunchly against veganism.
Whether that's veganism makes you ill,
young girls are going vegan
'cause they're trying to mask their anorexia or orthorexia,
that vegans kill more animals
that were destroying the Amazon rainforest.
There are these narratives that are consistently perpetuated
even though they're consistently debunked.
And there is this, I think,
issue with people's perceptions about veganism,
not coming from any, I suppose,
detailed research on their part,
but merely just because they've seen
sensationalist headlines about vegan activists.
It's this passive media consumption.
that is buttressed by the advertising industry
and dairy checkoff programs, et cetera,
that are feeding us this narrative
about how to eat made is to be masculine,
and if you're gonna be vegan,
you're a soy boy and that's for sissies and all of that.
So there's that kind of piece as well,
which for young men can be very powerful
as a lever in thinking about these issues.
It is so important.
And I think the meat and masculinity link
is a really important one for us to consider.
I suppose it's easy for us
to look at men who consume meat for that reason
and view them as being these really terrible people
who are just all about their ego
and are fragile in all of this.
But it kind of does a disservice
to the incredible amount of pressure
that comes from advertising,
that come from public perception and peer pressure.
And there are studies that show that
men can feel very disenfranchised in social environments
where they feel that their masculinity
is being questioned by their friends
and that they're less likely
to choose plan-based options in these social situations,
even if they rationally understand
the reasons to do so that, that peer pressure
and that societal pressure of these expectations
about what being a man means
and how that equates to diets
really puts a lot of burden on young men,
especially to fulfill that.
And of course there are lots of issues
with this kind of hyper masculine attitudes
that's perpetuated,
especially now I feel maybe more than has been in the past,
but I think overlooks
the fact that there is this concerted effort,
probably from many areas from industry
and also from the media to perpetuate that narrative.
You turn on the TV and these fast food chains
are using images of sexualized women
or images of men talking about eating meat like a man,
that's a message that's perpetuated a lot,
and it weighs heavy
on the psychology of young people growing up
and who they want to be
and how they feel they should conform.
Well, let's go through
some of the main arguments against being vegan
since you have fielded all of them.
At the top of that list really is this argument
around personal choice,
like get outta my business,
why are vegans always trying to make me go vegan,
live and let live.
Live and let live.
To let's say you,
Earthling Ed.
Let's say me.
Sometimes I think vegans can try and make the point
that it's not a personal choice if it affects someone else.
I hear that light.
It's not a personal choice because there's a victim,
but fundamentally it is a choice.
When we go into a supermarket or a restaurant,
what we choose to buy is up to us to decide,
no one else can make that decision for us.
So the first thing to recognize is it is a choice
but then by the recognition that it's a choice,
it means that we don't have to do that.
And when we talk about moral issues,
well, everything is a choice.
I could leave today, find someone and mug them, rob them.
I could find a dog and kick them and stomp them to death.
I can choose to do all of these things,
but they're not morally justified
as a consequence of being a choice.
So whilst we do to animals and what we choose to buy
when it comes to animal products,
isn't undeniably up to us to choose,
that doesn't mean
that it's justified as a consequence of that,
because every action moral or immoral is a choice.
And I suppose I always say,
what about the choice of the animals?
When we say about personal choice,
often people make the argument
that they're trying to protect people's sovereignty
and people's ability to make individual decisions
but what overlooks is the fact that our personal choice
is impacting the the desire of trillions,
of others around the world.
And so what about their choice, if they had that choice,
they wouldn't walk into a slaughterhouse in-
We're so detached from that equation, though.
It's very difficult for us to do that math
because of the distance and the barriers that are put up
to prevent us from really understanding that.
Plus the fact that it feels like my personal choice
has so little impact on this broader problem at large,
me ordering a cheeseburger
or picking up some ground beef at the supermarket,
isn't gonna really impact the state of factory farming.
But at the same I'm every mass movement for our history
has been formative individuals.
And so whilst as an individual making personal decisions,
we may feel like the impact that we have is small
and as an individual choice, it is.
But an individual choice
combined with millions of other individual choices
starts to have a huge impact.
And so it's about being empowered to recognize
what we can achieve.
And we look across the world and we look at so many problems
and as individuals,
there's very little we can do about that.
We can donate to charities, but can we stop war?
Not as an individual necessarily,
we can go protests and marches.
Sometimes that doesn't make a difference either, of course,
but when it comes to the agricultural system
and the way the food that we consumers produced
and the consequences of that,
is entirely something that we as individuals
and consumers have the power to change.
There are subsidy systems and there are legislative problems
from governments and politicians.
But fundamentally, if we, as consumers come together
and vote our wallets for a different world,
we can create a massive amount of change.
And so it's one of those rare issues, potentially,
where we as individuals have the power
to completely change that system.
So I think it's about being in power to recognize
the responsibility,
but also the ability that we have to bring about change.
And recognizing that capitalism, fundamentally
responds to shifts in demand.
So if the demand shifts and people are desirous
of plant-based milk options,
that's what you're gonna see in the supermarket
and of course, that is what we're seeing,
we're seeing the proliferation of plant-based options,
at not only restaurants across the world,
but the fast food outlets,
like they are responsive to consumer demand.
And to the extent that we can consolidate
and marshal the messaging around that demand
and get more people enthusiastic about this.
These companies, it's not mustache Sterling people
sitting around a boardroom
conspiring to make people unhealthy
and kill as many animals as possible.
They're trying to meet their quarterly earnings.
And if they figure out a way to do that,
by dent of exploring the plant-based world,
then that's exactly what they're going to do.
So I think it really is powerful,
and it's not dissimilar from this discussion
around individuation,
in the same sense
that we struggle to individuate these animals.
We have to also be able to understand
that the individuals amongst us
comprise a greater hole that is indeed very powerful.
And YouTube and podcasts and things like that,
I think have played a huge part in,
at a minimum, shifting the consciousness
of the younger generation to really care about these things.
Definitely.
What's unique about this issue in a sense is,
throughout history, we've never had the opportunity
to hear the other side of the story.
Parents, grandparents,
they were raised in until you the past 10 years or so.
What we knew about animal agriculture
came from animal agriculture.
We were told the animals are treated well,
why would we have question that?
We go into a soup market
and we see these promotional posters telling us one thing,
this is all we're feds, and this is all we hear.
So what's unique about now
is that we have this opportunity to go,
well, actually, is there some thing else to this is,
is there more to this,
is there an another side to this coin?
And when we can do that, look into that, see what happens,
there is this now growing awareness
about the impact that animal agriculture
has on the environment, on our health.
These things are stemming from a public awareness,
a shift in public consciousness
that is also stemming from a proliferation of information
through podcasts and YouTube that hasn't existed before.
So it's creating a unique situation
for us to engage with ideas
that potentially older generations
didn't have the luxury of engaging with.
I hear you Ed,
but I procure all of my meat from regenerative farms.
It's all locally raised, hormone free, the whole thing.
So I'm doing my part.
It's a common argument now, isn't it?
Regenerative.
And those animals
are important in regenerating the soil
which is a key to solving the climate crisis.
And regenerative is like the new sustainable word,
is the new the buzzword that these industries
are using a lot.
I think the first thing to recognize
is this idea that people are supporting these systems
comes from a good feeling.
It comes from the sense
that we need to do something differently,
but we're kind of still stuck in this paradigm
of wanting to continue consuming animals,
so we're trying to find rationalizations to continue that,
and this idea of regenerative beef farming
or lamb farming comes along
and it ticks the boxes
of allowing us to continue eating animals,
but also means we can regenerate the soils
and it gets rid of all the problems.
And it alleviates all of that cognitive dissonance.
It takes everything that we want, but is it true?
That's when it becomes a problem.
So the idea of regenerative animal farming is,
as you rightfully say,
it creates a system
which can put nutrients back in the soil.
It reduces the use of kind of artificial fertilizers
and crop production, can reduce the strain on places like,
the Amazon rain forest and such,
which is currently being decimated for feed production,
and cattle grazing, and all these terrible things.
But when we think about regenerative farming,
what we have to recognize
is that it uses up an incredible amount of land.
So if we think about the us, for example,
so the USDA states
that currently about 41% of the land mass of the US
is used for animal farming,
when it comes to plant farming
just for human consumptions it's only 4%.
So in the us 10 times more land
is used to produce animal products
than plant products for humans directly.
And when we look at beef farming in particular,
well, it's about 20% of the entire land mass
of the 48 contiguous US states is used to produce beef,
which makes about 3% of our caloric needs.
So this is with a system that uses feed lots.
this is with an efficient system when it comes to land use.
So simply put, even if we believed in regenerative farming,
we cannot continue to consume as much meat,
dairy, and eggs as we currently do.
It'll be a fraction of that anyway,
because there isn't the land or the resources
to produce the animal products or the quantity
that we currently consume use in these systems.
So even if it was a viable alternative,
we'd still be dramatically
reduce the amount that we consume.
But when we look at regenerative farming,
there's a couple of aspects to look at,
first is biodiversity and second is emissions.
Those are like the two main things
that proponents of this system of farming will talk about.
So when we look at biodiversity to begin with,
the idea is that grazing animals
increases biodiversity because of monocropping.
And of course in indoor factory farming
is terrible for biodiversity which it is,
but at the same time is grazing animals
the best thing for biodiversity, or is there an alternative.
And when we look at biodiversity,
it's very simple to recognize that forests, woodlands,
long grass Meadows, and wildflower Meadows
increase by more than grazing pasture lands do.
So what we need to do
is work out how we can maximize biodiversity gains.
So when we look at animal agriculture
and we look at it globally,
it uses 76%, sorry, it uses 83% of all agricultural land.
So over 4/5 of agricultural land is used to graze animals.
Now, if we switched to a plant-based diets,
we could reduce the amount of agricultural land that we need
by about 75%
and that's feeding everyone on a plant-based diet.
We can still reduce that amount of land by 75%.
So that means that we have all this land now
that we no longer need to use for agriculture,
that we can do something else with.
And the primary thing we can do with that land is rewild it.
And that just basically means returning the land
that we currently use for agriculture
back to some form of natural state,
whether that swamps, peatlands, forests, Woodlands,
wild flower Meadows, whatever it may be,
we can return that land back to nature
and as a consequence increase
the fauna of flora of the world,
increase the biodiversity that exists.
So that's what we need to do
if we want to prioritize biodiversity gains.
When it comes to emissions,
there is an idea that grazing animals, ruminant animals,
sequesters carbon into the soil, which it does,
and the reason it does that is through photosynthesis.
So when an animal grazes there to turning up the roots,
they're consuming the grass,
which is encouraging and stimulating
the regrowth of these plants,
which the sequesters carbon through photosynthesis
and stores carbon in the soil.
And something about
the way that they're walking on the land and seeding it
in some respects has some sort of beneficial impact.
Yeah, and then the manure
replaces some of the lost nutrients in the soil.
But there's a couple of ways looking at it,
firstly, from an emissions perspective,
when we look at the meta analyses
on these farming systems,
they're still producing net emissions.
So the grazing animals are still producing emissions.
And even in the most generous circumstances,
we're looking at only a 20 to 60% of emissions being offset
in these generative farming scenarios.
But I think what's really important about this is,
whilst soil is a carbon sink,
it's not a limitless carbon sink.
So after a period of time
soils reach something called soil carbon equilibrium,
which means the amount of carbon
that can be stored in the soils is, is maximized.
So at that point, even if grazing animals
offset all of the emissions that they produce,
which it doesn't, but even if it did,
at some point, the soil reaches full saturation of carbon.
Yeah, you saturate it and at that point
it's net emissions just-
100% emissions.
Not sequestration.
It really puts to the test,
the whole Allan Savory kind of philosophy around this.
And it's a study or an article called
like Grazed and Confused.
That is a really great read
that explains all of this in great detail.
Well, Allan Savory released this Ted talk,
which went super viral,
where he made the claim, I believe,
where it's something like, if just 50% of pasture lands
could reverse climate change or something
if there were grazed in the manner that he advocates for.
Which is an unsubstantiated claim and graze and confuse
is a great example, 'cause it looked at 300 sources
and it looked at all these farming scenarios
to try and work out whether there was any veracity
to the claims being made and realized that,
well, yes, it can sequester some carbon,
it's nowhere near gonna offset the emissions.
And with the soil-carbon equilibrium,
you reach a point where you're not offsetting anything.
So as a long term strategy, even if it did work,
there's no legs to it.
'cause at some point you either have to take the animals
and farm them on more land,
which means creating more agricultural land
or you have to stop the animal farming.
So when we talk about sequestering carbon,
the question becomes well,
is grazing animals the only way
that we can put carbon in the soils.
Because by having to offset
the emissions the animals produce,
we're limiting the capacity for our soils
to sequester carbon.
Why are we trying to offset these emissions
when we can just not have these emissions to begin with?
And if we weren't grazing cattle and lambs and such,
we won't have to offset the emissions they produce.
So again, when we look at sequestering carbon,
the best thing that we can do
is create forests and Woodlands and long grass Meadows
and wild flower Meadows
because that not only increases by diversity,
but it also sequesters carbon
and does so in a way about having to offset
any of the negative emissions
produced by the animals in the first place.
And just to be clear where generative farming
is far better than factory farming,
it is a step in a positive direction to some extent,
but it will never be able to scale the meat,
current meat demand.
It's not really a solution to any of these problems.
And the argument that it is a valid participant
in reversing climate change
is really the error in all of this.
It's dangerous.
The graze and confused study
said that only one gram protein per person per day
on average globally comes from solely grass fed animals,
just one gram.
We need obviously a lot more than that.
And when we look at animal products,
I think is something like, 20, 22 grams or something
is maybe coming from animal products right now.
So if we want to get the protein
that we get from animals right now,
but only from systems of solely grass fed production,
well, it's just not gonna be possible.
The United Nation says that 26% of Earth's ice-free land
is used for grazing animals,
that that's currently what it is.
So it has its benefits
when you compare it to factory farming.
Obviously these systems that these regenerative proponents
are talking about are substantially better in many ways
to the system that we currently have of mass feed production
and factory farming and the huge manure lagoons
that are obviously just terrible in so many ways.
But the question is, is it the best thing that we can do?
And does it genuinely solve the problems
that we're trying to address?
And when you view it against the alternatives,
a plant-based food system that's more sustainable,
but also reworded landscapes,
those concepts and that system of agriculture
and land management is substantially better
in every single way than a system of regenerative farming.
And often proponents of this way of thinking
the regenerative animal agricultural way of thinking,
we'll try and point the finger
at the way the current plant-based food system is set up.
And I see a lot of people-
You're gonna (indistinct) this,
but you're eating your monocropped,
factory farmed plant foods.
Well, firstly, if we swapped to a plant-based diet,
we would reduce arable land by 20% anyway.
So even just switching to a plant-based diet
would still be preferable
from an arable monocropping perspective,
just straight off the bat.
But I think what's disingenuous about that,
is it's trying to say
that there's no better way of producing plants.
I recognize that the plant-based food system
is far from perfect, it's significantly better,
but it doesn't mean that it's as good as it could be.
So by trying to say that regenerative animal farming
isn't a viable solution,
isn't saying that we shouldn't try
and make what we currently do better
when it comes to plant farming.
And we should be adopting
better forms of plant-based agriculture.
Regenerative plant-based farms.
Bingo.
Why not just do that.
Exactly, and then we've got things like vertical farms,
which an incredibly exciting prospect,
even when it comes to lab grow meat,
if you wanna look at producing meat sustainably,
lab grown meat will be when it's scaled up
and financially efficient enough
will be more sustainable than regenerative farming anyway.
So it's seen as kind of like this almost compromise,
but effectively it's still causing huge amounts of damage
to our environment
and of course resulting in premature death of animals.
And there's an alternative that exists
and will continue to become more sustainable
into the future as we engage
with these more technological advancements
within plant-based production as well.
So that kind of covers the environmental arguments
around regenerative agriculture.
But another thing that comes into play
when people are opting for grass fed beef,
is this idea that these animals
are living a much higher quality of life.
I think there's a lot of confusion
over the definition of grass fed
and how that definition is sort of weaponized
in a way that people, consumers who are trying to do better,
might not be aware of.
The idea behind grass feds,
a lot of it is kind of a marketing term
because grass fed animals
can still be fated on feed lots at the end of their life.
Like the last 15% of their life or something like that,
where they go, and then they're just eating grain
to get them as fat as possible.
Exactly.
And it's still considered,
it can be label grass fed.
That's right.
And I think the percentages may be vary country to country.
I think in Australia it might be as much as 25%
of their life, the final quarter.
So it doesn't mean that these animals
are very solely in these pastures.
And even on these pastures,
they can be supplemented with different feeds anyway.
And also there are still components
of animal agriculture that exists
such as the mutilations, the branding,
these things still exist,
even in grass fed farming productions.
And they're still killed in slaughterhouses as well.
So, people often say to me I'm against factory farming,
everyone, even if they support it, says they are against it
and likes to have this aspiration supporting
these kind of grass fed systems,
because again, it's seen compromise,
but ultimately when we view this issue
at its kind of most barest form,
it's again about this notion
of reducing exploitation and suffering and it's-
The animal's still getting a bolt in the head
and its throat cut, no matter what.
So it may be better quote/unquote,
but is it objectively the best thing that we can do?
No.
So we shouldn't be comparing this little scenario
to the extreme of factory farming,
we should be comparing it to the other side,
which is, not exploiting these animals in the first place
when it comes to the environment, when it comes to health
and when it comes to the ethics,
then not exploiting animals
is better in all of those different ways,
even compared to this middle kind of compromise if you like.
That opens the door to a conversation around
the sort of dark side of greenwashing or incremental change
because these small changes and the marketing
that kind of wraps around them
makes people feel better about their choices
and kind of ameliorates any type of activism
because people are sort of sedated
into believing that their actions
are lining up with their values, when in fact they're not.
We all like to be told good things about our bad habits
and greenwashing and this kind of concept humane washing
are really important tools that industries will use
and companies will use to make us feel good
about our bad habits.
And so a lot of us are familiar
with the concept of greenwashing
or companies trying to overstate
the sustainability impacts of their products,
but humane washing is something similar.
We're going to a supermarket,
we see a box of free range X
that's an example of humane washing.
It makes us think we're buying a product
that is quote/unquote humane.
And the names of the farms
and the picture of the red tractor
and the beautiful looking fields and all of that.
Exactly.
Or the five step welfare program or whatever it might be.
There are so many examples of it
because fundamentally these industries
and indeed the suppliers, the supermarkets
know that we care about these issues,
they understand that.
And they know that if we had, or we saw a label that said,
this piece of pig that you're about to buy
was slaughtered in the gas chamber, using this method
and they were raised in this way
and here's a picture of the farm.
We would probably go,
that tin of chickpeas seems pretty good now.
So they have to sell us an ideal
and they have to sell us what we want to buy.
And that's really dangerous because what we want to buy
is at complete odds of what we're actually buying.
So it's about being, I suppose,
again, a bit conscious of these choices that we're making
and the words humane is a really interesting word
because we use it all the time
to describe what we do to animals.
It's acceptable to kill an animal
if it's done in a humane way
or, what happens in China is obviously terrible,
but in the US or the UK,
our slaughterhouse is a humane
because they have these regulations.
But the word humane, if we open up a thesaurus
and we find synonyms means compassionate, benevolent, kind.
And if you're a humane person, you're inherently,
I guess, a good person, a kind person.
But then how do we benevolently or compassionately
exploit or kill someone against their need?
And sometimes people say you can't call an animal a someone,
I've heard this a lot recently, they're not a someone.
And I say, "Well, if they're not as someone,
what are they, something."
They're either an individual or an object.
When we use language in this way,
again, reaffirms this notion that what we do to animals
is a moral issue, when we recognize
that they are someones and not some things,
it makes the notion of doing something negatively to them,
cutting their throat, for example,
the idea that that's humane obviously becomes nonsensical,
but we're constantly sold this idea
of being high welfare, compassionate, nice for the animals,
the animals are happy to be a part of the system
when deep down, I think we all secretly realize
that that's not necessarily true,
but it's easier to believe the lies sometimes
than is to accept the uncomfortableness
of the truth in that scenario.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legume
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is The Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com,
and right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff, people
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
A lot of that is rooted in a lack of transparency,
like this, inability to make a connection, obviously,
and I watched this debate that you did on television
with the dairy farmer who said,
"Well, we are transparent and we have people come
and they visit the farm and we show them everything."
And you said,
"Do you show them the part where you slit the throat?"
And he said something like,
"I'd like to think that we're transparent about that."
And the host of the show to her credit said,
"Well, it's a yes or no thing.
Like, are you transparent about that or not?"
Clearly he's not, but he's on television,
he's trying to get through this experience.
And I don't see a future
in which there will be transparency around that.
And that is very much at odds with your generation
and the generation beneath you,
that demands a level of transparency
that my generation has sort of been myopic about.
Like that there is a consciousness
that is brought into consumer choice
that younger people have where they expect transparency
because they've acclimated to it,
'cause they've grown up with it.
And the idea that a corporation or an industry
would lack that is anathema.
Yeah, and I think there is also
a heightened sense of scrutiny now
where we don't just demand transparency
but I guess we also recognize
that these labels and these terms,
and these adverts should be scrutinized
and we shouldn't take everything on face value.
And I think that is something that's kind of emerging in new
and people are still maybe coming to grips with that.
Because yeah, fundamentally
these industries are not transparent
and the dairy farmer is a good example of that,
there is a perceived transparency,
there's an illusion of transparency
and that illusion of transparency can be perpetuated
when we drive and we see animals grazing.
In the UK, for example,
it's very common to see animals grazing, lambs, cows.
It's not an unusual thing to see.
So that creates this illusion of, firstly transparency,
but secondly, I guess this notion of being humane
because we think, well, how bad can it be
'cause I saw a dairy cow chewing on pasture earlier.
So there is this constant perpetuation
of this illusion of transparency.
And I think farmers themselves,
I think that they can be unconscious in that as well.
I don't think that that dairy farmer, for example,
knows that he's not being transparent
or thinks that he's not being transparent.
I think he thinks he's been very open.
he does these open farm Sundays
where members of the public
can come and see his cows grazing.
And I think he thinks that he is genuinely being
this very open, nothing to hide kind of farmer,
but farmers themselves don't go into the slaughterhouses.
Don't necessarily walk onto the kill floor.
they drop the animals off, drive away.
So even they themselves can often be,
I guess, oblivious or maybe willfully ignorant
to what happens in some of these places.
Of course they're aware, but even though themselves,
maybe don't have the full picture of transparency
that we would like them like them to have
and indeed they should have.
Because for a lot of farmers, it can be uncomfortable.
I've spoken to many farmers
who will say that dropping animals off at slaughterhouses
is really hard and they form connections with these animals,
but they kind of say,
well, we have to do what we have to do.
They've kind of found that justification
that allows that difficult moment
in this process of farming to occur,
this disconnection, this justification of,
well, we have to do it.
And when we justify something by saying, we have to,
it becomes easy to justify almost anything terrible
if we create the mentality, that it's a necessity.
And I think farmers do the same.
They convince themselves it's a necessity.
And therefore that makes dropping off these cows
that they maybe misguidedly,
but maybe themselves individually
really believe they have a connection with.
And I think that's hard.
So I think there's a lack of transparency everywhere
and a lack of, I guess, objectivity and honesty.
And of course that lack of transparency
makes it more difficult for us to understand
the emotional experience of the people
that actually work in these slaughterhouses
and have to operate in the kill room,
such that even if animal rights isn't your thing,
or you have a hard time like connecting with that
and you care about humans,
this should be an issue that you care about
because there are a lot of people that work in these places
who have to endure sort of psychic toll day in, day out.
And there's a lot of literature out there
about the long term emotional implications
of what it's like to be employed in that capacity.
It's a terrible job that none of us want.
There's a reason why slaughterhouses
are in kind of rural areas.
Often areas with little job opportunities
and quite simply put,
no one wants to work in slaughterhouse.
No one goes to school,
goes to college because that's what they want.
They are victims of circumstance, victims of environment.
There's incredibly high turnover rates in slaughterhouses
because people take these jobs
out of the feeling of necessity
and then they can't handle it.
And then those that do stay, find ways to handle it.
That might be drug and alcohol abuse.
It might be violence that perpetuates outside
or permeates outside of the walls of the slaughterhouse.
There are studies that show that in boomtown counties
near large slaughterhouses, the rates of domestic violence,
of rape, of assault, of violent crimes
is exponentially higher, exponentially increases.
And even when they look at the variables
and they look at other kind of maybe working class jobs,
such as, steel production car production,
those rates of violent crime increases aren't seen,
it's something very unique to slaughterhouse work.
And it's very easy to understand why that is.
most of us would never want to kill one animal.
Now I'm imagining slaughterhouse where eight hours a day,
five, six days a week, or killing hundreds,
thousands maybe of animals.
That your job is to endlessly pull a knife
across someone else's throat.
How do you reconcile with that?
How do you leave at the end of the day
and not bring that home of you?
We expect slaughterhouses workers
to hang up the blood soaked aprons
and the then just be these
completely mentally competent people at the end of the day
and that's an unfair thing for us to place on these people.
And then on top of that,
not only are they having the pressure of the job,
but they have the pressure of being low incomes
being in deprived areas where they feel completely trapped
because there isn't the availability
of working in a different place.
That's the job,
that's the job.
And if
you don't have that job,
then maybe you can't afford to live.
Maybe you'll be homeless.
Maybe you can't feed your family,
and you've got kids to look after.
There are all of these extra pressures and burdens
that can lead people to doing things
that they wouldn't want to do,
but they feel they have no choice to,
and we're fulfilling them
and creating that scenario for our purchases.
And it's a terrible industry in every a re conceivable way,
even for the humans in that scenario.
That doesn't detract from the fact that what they're doing
is obviously morally wrong,
but they are merely fulfilling the expectations
of the people who are paying for it.
The blood is on their hands literally,
but we're the ones who are really have the blooded hands,
'cause they're the ones paying
for these things to exist in the first place.
And I've talked about this before,
but a version of that scenario scales up
as you go up the chain of command at these farms
because most of them are
controlled through debt structures
by these large food companies
like Tyson and Cargill, et cetera,
who basically underwrite the construction
of these massive farms and create a system
in which it's very difficult to meet your debt demands,
creating a certain type of indentured servitude
with these farmers that they can never really scale out of.
They have to continue to grow or perish essentially.
And that's not what, a lot of these people
who farming has been in their family for generations
kind of signed up for.
Certainly not.
I mean, they would is a huge boom in these corporations
in 1980s with Smithfields, Tyson, JBS of course,
and they have a complete monopoly of the market.
In the UK, we have a similar thing with like Moy Park,
which is a big chicken producer, 2 Sisters,
So it's a similar thing across many countries,
not just in the US,
but the US is a uniquely terrible problem with it,
which is just,
these huge companies,
they sign contracts of all these producers
and it's mainly poultry producers and pig producers.
And those farmers
who maybe don't want to sign these contracts
are faced with a problem,
which is that these companies
with the farmers who are contracted to them
are constantly driving down the cost of production.
And driving down the cost of production,
they're producing cheaper and cheaper food,
which means that these kind of more independent farmers,
they can't financially operate in the strains of the market
because it's costing them so much more to produce
the food they produce.
And no one's gonna buy it.
The suppliers and distributors,
aren't gonna pay the same amount of money
for it to cover the costs.
And so a lot of these farmers end up their hands tied
because they have to sell into these corporations.
And as you say, they then have all these debts
and the contracts might stipulate
that they have to update their machinery every so often,
have to update the methods of farming.
And so those are more debts, more loans,
more financial problems.
And so they become trapped in the system
where they can't really get out
by incurring huge financial problems,
which again could make them homeless,
could mean they have to leave their communities,
not be able to support their families.
And so there is this external pressure
which we often don't realize,
which is constantly fueling the continuation
of these industries.
And many farmers may wake up one day
and not want to continue farming
for whatever reason that might be,
maybe an ethical realization,
but then have no choice based in the financial strains
that have been incurred
due to these corporations and companies
and the monopolization they have on the markets.
The other big argument that I want to talk about
is this idea that,
if you wanna kill the maximum number of animals,
the best way to do that is to go vegan.
So this is an argument that was promulgated
by the great Ted Nugent
on the Joe Rogan experience recently,
and I've heard this one fielded before many times,
and we can kinda get into that a little bit,
but explain the basis for this argument
and then let's try to deconstruct it.
The basis for the argument
stems from something which is absolutely true,
which is that plant-based farming
still results in animal death,
crop production, harvesting results in animals being killed.
We can't get around that for the time being.
So it's always important
that when we advocate for veganism myself,
I have to make the important consideration,
which is that veganism isn't perfect.
It's not gonna eliminate all exploitation.
It's gonna not gonna eliminate all death.
It's really a reduction of these things,
a huge reduction, but a reduction, nonetheless.
So it comes from an important point to recognize,
which is that veganism isn't perfect.
And we're not devoid of harm by choosing plant-based foods.
But the problem is it is kind of extrapolated
it's up into this really overexaggerated thing
where vegans are killing all these mice
and these rodents and all these birds
and all these of other animals at the same time.
And well, first that's not strictly true.
when we think about rodents and we think about birds,
it's very hard to, to catch a mouse,
let alone run them over with a combine harvester.
They've put like radio trackers on these animals before,
harvested fields and then found
that the population just haven't really been decimated.
They just kind of go leave the fields.
You've got big combine harvester making all this noise,
noise vibrations in the ground,
the animals don't stick around.
But insects of course are killed
and will be killed on massive in crop production.
And the idea is, I suppose,
to try and create a sense of hypocrisy
that vegans are causing death,
so therefore there's no point being vegan,
but of course it's about reducing the harm that we cause.
And when we look at crop production for animals,
we look at the mass production of feed in south America
for animals,
Even if we just take the system that we have now,
significantly more animals are gonna be killed
in the production of animal foods,
because not only do you have 80 billion land animals
and 0.8, 2.3 trillion marine animals,
but then you also have all the animals
that are killed in crop production as well
to feed the animals who we farm,
including the farmed fish
who are fed things like soy and stuff as well.
So it's a problem that exists for plant-based farming,
but the problem that exists there,
exists in all of the animal agriculture space
and on top of that,
you have all the violence that's committed to the animals
who we eat directly as well.
So it's kind of a non-starter in that sense.
A couple things, first of all, the mice thing,
the flash point for that was a study or an article
that was misinterpreted
because it was completely focused
on a situation in Australia
where they have like this rampant crazy mouse epidemic
that surfaces from time to time that they have to deal with.
And so those numbers were sort of co-opted and extrapolated
to make a broader argument that isn't necessarily accurate
outside of Australia.
Yeah, exactly.
The mouse plague argument.
Yeah, that was run with globally.
And as you say, it was used to try and paint a picture
of the global agricultural scene.
But yeah, the mouse players are just these random events,
which occur where there's a huge growth in mice populations
and they just overrun fields and people's homes.
But again, the problem is,
these mice aren't just targeting fields
that are used to produce crops, they're used for humans-
They're going everywhere.
Everywhere.
And most of the crops anyway
are growing food for the animals.
Yeah, exactly.
They hay, straw, barley types of grass
for animals and animal product production.
So it's kind of, again, a non-starter in the sense of,
yes, of course, farmers will kill these mice
when they're trying to protect
the food they've grown directly for humans,
but the problem exists for feed
and crops being produced for animals
and more of that land is being used for animals.
So more mice have been killed
for the animal production in the first place anyway.
Yeah.
I think it is important to,
one of the things you said earlier is,
in terms of like how you interact with people
when you have these conversations
is to acknowledge the merits in your counterparts argument.
And I think it is important for vegans
in the vegan community
to at least acknowledge that
when they're buying something under the impression
that it's cruelty free,
to some extent that's true,
but nothing that we do,
lack a certain kind of downstream impact.
I had, "The Biggest Little Farm"
did you see that documentary?
"The Biggest Little Farm".
I'm familiar with it.
I've not seen it.
Yeah, it's nearby here.
And I had them on the podcast and he was explaining to me
that when he was trying to grow avocados,
that the gophers kept eating the trees
and they had a gopher for problem or whatever.
And in order for these trees to grow,
there had to be a certain amount.
He was like, listen,
"I don't wanna kill any of these animals."
But he felt like he had to in order for this crop to thrive.
So his point being,
obviously when you're buying your avocado,
you need to understand that it's not as simple
or as elementary as you might imagine.
And I said, yeah, you have to acknowledge that.
Like you have to acknowledge
that there's a kernel of truth in this,
and if we wanna be good advocates for this lifestyle,
we have to acknowledge
where things are not as black and white
as perhaps we wish they were.
Of course, I mean, nothing is black and white really.
And you're absolutely right.
We have to acknowledge the imperfections
of what we advocate for as well.
And then we can improve those on the Joe Rogan podcast,
it was a different one with a guy called Chris Kresser,
who James Wilks went against
when he did the game changers debates.
And in this other episode, Chris Kresser has this study
and he used this to provide justification
for the argument that vegans kill animals,
which is again is true,
but not necessarily in the scale
that they like to think it is.
And he used this one, I think it says 7.2 billion animals
are killed in crop production in the US.
But the conclusion of the article is that firstly,
those numbers are overexaggerated
and take extreme measurements.
And secondly, that we can work to produce plants
in a way that reduces that.
And with things like vertical farming
with things like indoor crop production
in these kind of like underground
dwelling basements as well, there's no animal deaths.
So of course right now the system isn't perfect,
but the recognition that it's not perfect
then allows us to push ourselves to make it better.
Sure.
Which is something
we can absolutely do in plant farming as well.
Just back to this idea,
if you wanna kill a lot of animals go vegan
and what a strong man argument that is.
I mean, you made a video about this
where you state some really impactful data,
not the least of which is 75 to 80% of all soy
is grown for animal feed, only 6% is for humans.
And 9.5 billion land animals are killed in the US alone.
And that's something like 55 billion if you include fish,
77.3 million acres are in the us for plants for humans,
but 127.4 million for animal feed.
So animal farming uses 10 times more land,
83% of all global land use is used for animal farming.
So, it's crazy when you look at it through that lens,
that the idea that like vegans are the problem here.
It doesn't make sense.
And also not to mention
the downstream implications of animal farming,
like let's just take poultry farms
and the waste and the runoff
and how that gets into our water systems
and kills biodiversity in rivers
and creates algae blooms in the ocean,
like, are we counting those deaths
and that damage as well when we're making this calculation?
Definitely not.
And what's even scariest still
is the numbers that we have when it comes to slaughter
are just the animals that reach slaughter,
so it doesn't take into account all the animals
who die on farms, which is in the tens of millions again.
So the data that we have,
or the data that we often use
is not even representing the full scale of the problem.
I mean, in the UK,
we have the worst water bathing quality in Europe
and our rivers are all polluted with chemicals
and some of that sewage,
but the biggest cause of that problem in most of our rivers
is run off from the agriculture industry,
animal agriculture often, mostly.
And even when it comes to like free range, chicken farming,
it's free range, poultry farming,
that's polluting one of our biggest rivers, the River Y.
And that would be a system of farming
that we would think is more sustainable and more ethical,
but that's actually causing the problem
when it comes to the pollution of this river
across England and into Wales and such,
so it is a huge fully encapsulating issue
that we can often try and I suppose,
ignore or demean by pointing at these straw man arguments
and Ted Nugent in that clip with Joe Rogan
goes off on this wonderful spiel
about how if you eat the tofu sandwich,
it's really terrible for all these reasons.
And he tries to link that into,
I think like deforestation in the Amazon.
But when you look at the data in south America,
for example, this report that 96%
of all the soy produced in south America
is used as animal feed for soy, like cooking oil
so not in tofu, not in soy milk, not in tempeh,
the meat alternatives, but animal feed and then cooking oil,
which is easily avoided, of course.
And even Ted Nugent,
he had this really kind of completely bewildering post,
where he shared all these bags of soy pallets that he had,
that he feeds to the deer that he hunts.
So he has the like canned hunting,
he has deer in this enclosed space.
He feeds them soy to fatten them up
and then shoots them to eat them
and then goes on Joe Rogan
and parades vegans eating tofu, 'cause it's made from soy.
It was this kind of wonderful moment of this pure irony.
Well, it's also a dig at the soy boy idea.
It's not a mistake that he chose soy to that point, right?
Certainly not, unfortunately.
How about this one?
Ed we've eaten meat for thousands and thousands of years,
this is how humans developed,
meat was fundamental
to our brains being the way that they are,
and being vegan is just extreme,
like let's just be balanced and prudent.
A good argument, isn't?
I hear it a lot.
Obviously we have to meat for thousands of years,
eating meat allowed us to survive
during times of food scarcity, during cold spells,
allowed us to evolve
and become the species that we are today.
There's no denying that meat has formed a cornerstone
of human history and indeed survival in many ways.
But the point is it's about where we're at now
and in a current con current modern day society
we know we don't have to eat meats,
and we can hardly make the argument
that going to McDonald's is helping us survive
or helping us evolve.
Quite the opposite fact.
So, meat consumption now is destroying our species,
destroying the planet, causing all sorts of problems.
So actually it's no longer even serving the purpose
that it used to in the past.
So it's happens now and now we don't need to.
So it's irrelevant.
The longevity of an action
doesn't provide justification for it to continue.
But the brain evolving one, I think is super interesting.
There's the idea that eating meat
allowed our brains to grow.
But actually when you look at something,
I suppose, a little bit more logical,
it makes more sense
that it was the consumption of carbohydrate dense foods,
tubers, potatoes, wheat, rice
that allowed our brains to grow.
Because our brain's primary fuel is glucose.
And so when we think about carbohydrate dense foods,
these are the foods that provide us with the most glucose.
So when we started cooking foods
and we started to being able to digest things like potatoes
and wheat and rice and such,
it allowed our body to consume more glucose.
And as a consequence of that, would presumably allow,
I mean, our brains could grow bigger.
And even when they look at sort of DNA
and they look at in a fossilized remains of people,
they identify enzymes in our mouths
that were there to help us break down starches
and to break down carbohydrates and digest them.
And so all the evidence points
to the fact that carbohydrates
were not only an essential part of our diet,
but were the reason that we were our brains grew
because we were providing our brains
to the fuel source that it needs to work most optimum.
But even if the meat brain argument were to be true,
we live in a society now
where we don't have to be obligate omnivores,
we can choose to be herbivores
and the science is pretty clear
that you can thrive on a vegan diet at any age,
whether you're pregnant or a small child,
we're both living examples of that.
So again, it goes back to choice.
Absolutely.
Like you can spend
all your time making those arguments
about whether we're herbivores or omnivores
and looking at our teeth and all of that,
but to me, like none of that really matters.
It's like here we are living now
and you look at the many harmful
implications of the way that we consume meat
and treat our animals.
And it doesn't make sense.
No.
And again, yeah, you are obviously right.
We can get bogged down with a forward facing eyes.
I hear that a lot, or-
Well, I haven't heard
that one, what's that one?
Forward facing eyes are the signs of a predator.
Pray have eyes that can see all around
'cause it allows them to see predators more easily.
Because we have forward facing eyes, the canine teeth,
even though our canine are really quite rubbish.
And the lion thing, it always goes back to the lion.
What is that?
I have no idea.
It's so baffling, I don't think it's like-
Like lions do this.
Like all these guys walking around
thinking that they're lions.
It's bizarre, isn't it?
Yeah.
On the one hand
I'll have conversations
and the same person
will tell me that humans are different to animals
'cause we're more intelligent.
And then later in the conversation they'll go,
well humans are animals and so are lions.
And so it's this irony.
Which one is it?
Which one is it? Exactly.
But we do like to compare ourselves to other animals
because again, I think we're trying to constantly appeal
to the idea that it's natural and normal
and that it's acceptable for us to do it
because there's a historical precedence,
a historical precedent, sorry,
and there's like this kind of naturalistic precedent
that exists with whatever animals do.
But again, we can get bogged down on that.
But the point remains now where we are,
with the information that we have,
with the food that we have available to us,
with the knowledge that we have, we don't have to.
The fact that we have forward face eyes
doesn't mean that we're now justified
to cause so much suffering to animals
when we could just eat the plants instead.
That's a very good point.
In all of these interactions and conversations
that you've had on college campuses with young people,
have you ever met an argument that you couldn't manage?
Like what do you think is the strongest argument
that you've had to field against veganism?
I think it's, people's personal health situations.
sometimes someone might say something to me about
the health of a family member
and I'm not necessarily sure how to respond to that,
I don't know the nuances and intricacies
of that individual scenario.
When it comes to like the moral issues,
when it comes to the environmental issues,
I've never heard anything that's made go, oh
that's something I'm not sure how to respond to,
or, oh that's a point I'm not considered.
But I think that people can
come up with these health arguments that-
They need this or I tried it
and this is what happened to me.
And it could be hard to argue against that,
because without knowing the personal situations,
what people were eating,
if they were supplementing how they were gonna about it,
it's hard to necessarily tell
that their experience was wrong in that scenario.
It's just more of a case
of trying to explain to people
that perhaps there was a deficiency
or something you could have done differently
to try and negate those problems.
But I think more broadly than that,
something that I really empathize with
is when people talk about family scenarios,
social situations.
That's and like the huge limiter.
It is.
And I think that's one of the biggest drivers for people.
It is just those social environments,
whether it's with family,
whether it's with friends.
100%
And that's the thing-
They could be
completely convinced that this is the right thing to do
and they could have a deep rooted desire to do it,
but their environment and their surroundings prevent it
because the social ostracization,
or just the drain of having to contend with that
is too burdensome for a lot of people.
And use that word ostracization,
which is a really important word to use
because humans we're social animals,
we thrive being in communities, being with others
and throughout history,
our survivalist depended on participation of others.
Having these communities where we had these roles
where we could integrate together
and being outside of that,
not having that sense of community,
being ostracized was catastrophic.
So now when we think of veganism,
it can be perceived as kind of a form of self ostracization.
We're removing ourself from the safe of the community,
the safety of the tribe, the safety of our social groups.
And so it can be very daunting
because it seems like we're stepping
outside of the comfort zone
and there's a historical kind of primal fear of doing that
because of the reliance that we had on others for survival.
It's different now, of course, but that primal fear,
I still think remains.
And so one of the most important things about being vegan
is that it normalizes being vegan
and it makes it more accessible for others.
And it's kind of like a snowball effect
where the more people who go vegan,
more people will go vegan
simply because more people are going vegan
and it becomes more normal and more accepted.
And that's how we can hopefully help people
in those environments.
But, I mean, I totally hear people
when they say that because it is hard
to look a family member
or go into a meal or a social situation
where everyone's doing one thing and you used to do that
and they're expecting you to continue doing it
and then tell them you're not.
And then explain their reasons why you're not.
And also be aware that they're gonna give you
loads of excuses to why you are wrong.
And you are gonna have to feel those excuses
while still trying to enjoy yourself
and not treading anyone's toes and upset anyone
or cause an argument.
That's exceptionally daunting.
So, whilst it doesn't morally justify what we do,
I totally empathize with people in those environments.
And I think it's about creating a sense of normality
around being vegan so that it becomes more accepted,
becomes more mainstream,
becomes something that people don't feel is intimidated by.
With family, I think especially my family, aren't vegan,
they're perfectly supportive of what I do,
but they're not necessarily open minded
to hearing why I do what I do.
And when it comes to family,
I think what's particularly challenging
is our parents hopefully try and raise us
to be kind of good people with good morals, good values.
They want us to integrate into an everyday society
and be good citizens.
Hopefully that's the idea.
And so when we turn around to our parents
and we say, look, I've gone vegan.
And in my situation, it was
"Look, I've gone vegan
because I think what we do to animals is wrong."
I'm kind of criticizing their parenting.
I'm saying that they raised me with bad morals,
that they raised me with bad values.
And for a parent to hear that,
and in the case of my parents,
I know they try to raise me to be hopefully a good person,
to hear that, even though I'm not explicitly stating that,
but I'm implicitly stating it,
I think it's hard for a parent to hear.
And so there are these dynamics, social, familial
that are very challenging for us to acknowledge and address
and can be very intimidating.
There's these social structures,
these hierarchies that exist within families
and for a child to go to their parent and say,
something like that, I think can be daunting
and challenging for a parent to hear.
And I understand that can then make it difficult
for people to want to make that change.
I'm very compassionate about that.
And we should just acknowledge the fact
that we're having this conversation in Los Angeles
and you hail from London,
like these are incredibly vegan, friendly environments.
And most people don't live in places like that, right?
And I think that speaks to another criticism or argument
against veganism, which is this idea that it is elitist.
And I think there is a strain of this movement
that has been co-opted by a kind of elitist notion
because in this burgeoning wellness industry
where high priced items are associated with
kind of living your best life,
going to the fancy markets
and getting the latest superfood and all of that,
veganism gets kind of wrapped up into that narrative
and creates an aspirational lifestyle perhaps,
but an inaccesible one for a lot of people
that turn them off to,
the stronger arguments
that all route back to this idea of moral philosophy.
I think part of the problem is use the word wellness.
I think that planet diets and veganism
have become somewhat synonymous
with this idea of individual wellness.
And that's why I always try and emphasize
that veganism is a moral issue
where obviously it has-
Well it's also about collect wellness.
Collective wellness is true.
But I suppose when we're talking about
the pricier things that we can buy,
there is this idea that it's kind of fulfilling
that stereotype of maybe an LA person
who's into those kind of those pursuits.
And so I think I try and acknowledge that veganism
is a moral philosophy
and there are people who eat vegan on a budget.
And of course you can be an expensive vegan.
You can go to Whole Foods or Erewhon
or whatever it may be and spend a lot of money
buying meat substitutes and stuff,
but that's not what veganism is.
Veganism is about trying to reduce the harm we cause.
And there was a study
that just came out from University of Oxford
by a professor called Marco Springmann
and he was looking at food prices
and he said in the UK, at least,
shopping and buying whole foods.
So the healthier plant-based foods
reduces your food bill by about 1/3.
So you can save money doing it that way.
But there is this connotation of bean vegan
means eating beyond burgers and impossible burgers
and and kind of like superfood powders and stuff.
And that's not what it is.
And it's great if you wanna do that.
I mean that, all power to you, if that's what you wanna do,
but it doesn't have to be like that.
And I think just trying to help people understand
that veganism doesn't mean having to shop in these places,
but can mean shopping and buying whole foods,
legumes, whole grains, potatoes,
all these foods that should make up the majority
of our diet anyway.
It is a really important way of making sure
that we can break through that elitist stereotype.
Now it is important to recognize
that there are people who live across the world,
but even in the US that don't have the means
to be able to live as comfortably as you and I do.
Of course now that's fairly obvious
and the way this socio-economic structure is set up,
there are situations of food disparity
where people don't have the accessibility
that we're used to where we live.
And we have to look at how we can challenge that
and change that.
Now there is something fundamentally wrong
when buying a beef burger from McDonald's
is cheaper than buying a pun a blueberries
from a supermarket, there's obviously something wrong
because the production of animal products
costs a lot more than the production
of fruits and vegetables and whole grains.
So it shouldn't be that way.
But the way that the system is set up now
is that huge amounts of subsidies are given to agriculture
and animal agriculture receives the most amount of subsidies
to drive down production costs
and make it cheaper for consumers.
At the same time as doing that,
we have the system of factory farming,
which drives down production costs even further.
So we're just constantly finding ways
to bring down the cost of these foods.
And then these fast food chains are opening up in areas
where people don't have the money
to be able to maybe travel to some supermarkets.
They don't have the money
to be able to rent a car to pick up groceries
and who don't have supermarkets in their area
and the availability and accessibility
that a lot of us have.
And so are forced out of that situation
to feed their families on a budget,
which can often mean buying
this subsidized cheaply, produced meat, dairy, and eggs.
So we have to challenge that system.
And the best way we can do that is firstly
being vegan ourselves
and asking for a different food system in general.
And then through doing that,
we can start to ask for a change in subsidy policy.
For example, according to Bloomberg last year,
the agriculture industry in the US
had its third most profitable year in half a century.
But how does that make sense
because it was during the pandemic.
Restaurants were shut down, there was food problems.
And the reason why, was because there was so much money
given in bailouts and subsidies.
So the animal farming industry had a very profitable year
because of the government handouts
that were granted to them.
So if we can reverse that situation
where we can stop giving subsidies to harmful industries
and instead use these subsidies
to drive down production costs for plant foods,
to incentivize technological advancements
in the plant-based food space,
we can alter the price of these products,
make them more accessible and available.
And by being vegan,
we're changing the supply and demand scenario,
which means that beyond meat and Oatly
and all these plant-based companies can scale at production,
can reduce costs over time as well.
And what we can do is we can reverse the current paradigm,
which is that meat, dairy, and eggs are generally cheaper
and plant-based alternative are generally more expensive
and make not only whole foods even more inexpensive,
but also meet people's demand for the alternatives as well
in a way that is more financially viable.
It's a broken system.
Yeah, it really is.
And I despair of the lack of political will
to untie this knot around subsidies
that's driving so many of these problems.
It's one thing to speak about the grassroots movement
and shifting demand through aggregating consumer habits
around healthier choices,
but the change also has to come from the top down
in terms of government getting its head around this.
When you see this sort of musical chairs that occurs
between governing bodies and regulatory bodies,
and C-suites of these giant food companies,
it's easy to like lose my ability
to be enthusiastic about a potential good future
in terms of fixing this problem.
Yeah, it's daunting and it may sound slight depressing,
but even right now, the us US Secretary of Agriculture
is a guy called Tom Vilsack
and before he was the current secretary of agriculture,
he was the CEO of the Dairy Export Council.
And this is normal operating procedure.
It's just a revolving door.
So it is troubling.
And I think this is why we as consumers
have to feel more because our elected officials
currently aren't gonna change anything.
Yeah, no one's coming to save us.
No.
So I guess there is,
yeah, there is an empowering,
that's something that can provide us with a sense of agency.
Definitely.
Even think about climate change and environmental policies
and the green new deal
and these issues that have been spoken about now,
when Al Gore released an on being in truth,
they weren't being spoken about.
So something's changed
and I think that's because there is now an appetite
within society for these to become political issues.
Now, politicians just generally follow the trend
of what is seen as a viable voting concept.
And right now changing subsidies
from animal agriculture to plant-based farming
isn't a viable voting concept.
It's not gonna win votes, it'll probably lose votes.
So we have to make these issues
something that politicians will stand on,
because I'm sure there are politicians
that would be more outspoken who maybe would agree,
but they don't want to risk jeopardizing the votes
that they have and the constituents they represent.
So we as consumers have to make that choice first.
And then we have to demand
that there is legislative change
that is implement as a consequence
of us wanting it to happen.
'Cause it won't happen
if we keep perpetuating the same systems we currently do.
Yeah, even at COP26,
animal agriculture wasn't really on the agenda
to be discussed, which is just infuriating,
it's unbelievable.
It's crazy, isn't it?
Even at COP20, this Tom Vilsack,
the secretary of agriculture here in the US,
whilst everyone was debating
about reducing MEFA emissions by 30%, by 2030,
he was saying to the press that in the US,
there is no need to reduce the amount of meats or livestock
that have been produced, during COP26 said that.
And it's just contradicting all of the sciences coming out,
even from the United Nations who are telling us,
we need to switch to plant-based food systems,
we need to transition in that direction.
While they're breaking for lunch and going and eating,
cheeseburgers and stuff like that.
It's so frustrating.
It's just like unbelievable.
You did a podcast with Jack Harris a while back
where you guys discussed this under this rubric of like,
can you be an environmentalist if you're not vegan,
and it was kind of a broader conversation
around what advocacy means and how we define it.
But certainly in the wake of COP26,
it's like, guys, we need to sit down and talk.
Seriously.
Like, what are we we doing?
It's very frustrating
that there has been such little conversation about this.
And I think I mentioned in the book
that there have been some kind of studies
that have shown that when you look at articles
about climate change,
I don't know, like a few percent of them
even mention a agriculture, let alone make that a focus.
So even within these,
I suppose what you'd consider to be friendly, media outlets,
places like The New York Times or The Guardian
or wherever it might be,
where we would like to think that they would be the ones
to maybe talk about this issue.
There is still a reluctance to mention it.
There is still a reluctance
to tell people about these problems.
Even with George Monbiot just like going nuts
in The Guardian all the time.
I mean, thank goodness that he exists
and that he's our voice in The Guardian,
'cause if it wasn't for him,
it would feel like we had no one backing us up
in that media space.
And it's very frustrating
because people need that normalization of these ideas
in the media, they consume,
there's something called the elusory truth effect,
which that basically the more you hear something,
the more you are likely to believe that it's true
even if it isn't.
And so if we're constantly hearing
that consuming meat, dairy eggs is fine, it's not a concern.
it's moral, it's humane.
We're gonna believe that even if that's not the case.
And so we need this proliferation of content
telling people why that's not true
so that we can challenge this elusive truth effects,
so that we can challenge this current paradigm of the media
and people's perceptions of veganism
being something that's bad
when in effect it's incredibly good in so many ways.
Well, it's a good news, bad news thing.
The bad news is mainstream media
isn't gonna cut onto that narrative anytime soon,
but there's stuff like this and what you do
that's becoming increasingly
more and more salient and powerful
in terms of shifting citizen ideas
around these important topics.
Certainly that's the important thing
about social media, isn't it?
And I think the important thing about people realizing
that their voice is valuable and important
and that we have hour to influence
our immediate social circles.
There's a consequence of that.
There's a ripple effect, where we influence those people,
they can influence the people in their social circles
and we, as individuals can achieve a lot
and it can be disheartening of course,
to see that there are these subsidy policies
and there are these corporations, monopolizing markets
and there is this proliferation of misinformation,
that is demoralizing,
it can feel like we're up against this
almost unassailable beast of a problem,
but ultimately there are happening
and there are cracks forming
in the the, otherwise sturdy armor of these industries,
the cracks are forming and we are starting
to get the message heard by people
who maybe wouldn't have heard it otherwise.
I think it's just really important to recognize
that change comes from individual action,
forming a mass movement, a collective action,
and we can all be a part of that. So it's about working out
what we want the future to look like.
Do we want this future to be a future
which does seek to reduce suffering
that does seek to create fairer more equal food systems.
That means that people can have options,
can have accessibility
and availability of healthy plant-based foods.
Do we want people to be more empowered
to make individual choices?
Do we want people to feel empowered to recognize
that they themselves are a part of this huge planet,
but also a very small planet
where we have the power to influence change
for the choices that we make.
And veganism is a stepping stone, I think,
to recognizing the broader impact
that we all have collectively, but also individually.
And it's by no means the only step we need to need to take,
but it a huge step in the right direction
in fixing, tackling, addressing, acknowledging
so many different issues
that up until this point,
we have often turned blind eye too, sadly.
Ordinarily, I would say that would be a great place
to like put a pin in it,
'cause it was like this super compelling monologue
that was delivered.
But there's a couple more things
I wanna talk to you about.
I wanna learn a little bit about Surge,
which is your nonprofit organization
that you founded or co-founded several years ago
that also has a media arm and now you have a sanctuary,
like how do you make all of the, these things work?
And I wanna talk about the restaurants too.
I'm super lucky to have a supportive community around me
of people who work in the sanctuary,
who do the day to day stuff there,
looking after these animals, we have over 130 animals now.
So, there's a wonderful group of people
that are doing the day to day work there,
So yeah, my partner and I, we founded it five years ago now
and we've just recently been growing the team.
We've got editors, animators, writers.
And so it's just been a really wonderful process
of us having this idea of what we want to achieve and do,
but then finding other people that are mission aligned
and incredibly talented people
and having them part of this process
as well has been really rewarding.
The animators and the filmmakers and the editors
that you have are unbelievable.
Like the quality of the content that you're putting out
is so elevated
in comparison to everything else that's out there.
So I would encourage you to keep going.
I certainly will.
And part of Surge
is funded by Unity Diner, right?
So you opened this restaurant.
That's also ostensibly a nonprofit
because the funds are channeled right back into Surge.
That's right.
So we had this idea a few years ago
that we wanted to do something
that kind of gave back the community,
but also could be used as a method of raising funds
to allow us to do some of things that we wanted to do,
primarily open the animal sanctuary that we currently have.
So we came up this idea of like a restaurant
where it would be operating on a nonprofit basis,
where as you say,
the money would go into funding Surge projects.
So we've done like two ads advertising around London
and the money's gone towards opening the animal sanctuary
that we now have have in the kind of middle of England.
And so, yeah, it was just an idea that we had
and it kind of snowballed very quickly.
And then we were like, oh my goodness,
we have this restaurant,
none of us know what we're actually doing.
So fingers crossed we can work it out.
And it's been amazing, amazing to meet so many people.
And it's given me a newfound awareness
of the importance of food.
I think that this thing about veganism
is kind of like a jewel process
where we need to give people the reason why,
but we also have to give people the how,
and without the how the food the delicious alternatives,
the recipes that exist.
We can talk about the why as much as we like,
but people won't make that change.
And having non-vegans come in and try plant-based food,
or at least try some of these plant-based foods
for the first time, the burgers, hot dogs,
whatever it might be.
And hearing them say about how they never realized
that plant-based food could taste like this,
or they never realized they could have fish and chips
that's vegan, for example, is a really rewarding thing.
That's the good, it's the no catch company
that you just started.
How many of those do you have now?
We have one currently,
which was just opened-
Brighton.
In Brighton.
So it's a completely vegan fish and chip shop,
and fish and chips in the UK is a big thing,
it's like a huge industry.
And I was raised on fish and chips,
like so many British people were,
and it's a really damaging industry.
And plant-based seafood options
are kind of few and far between,
it's still like a very new niche emerging market.
And we have this tow fish product
that we sell at Unity Diner which people love,
it's my favorite thing.
And we were like, why don't we do something
that try and takes on the fish and chip shop industry
that shows is that we don't have to keep
pillaging our oceans
and killing trillions of marine animals all the time,
but we can do it different way.
And so we open up the shop in Brighton,
which has been really well received so far
and our plan is to open up more,
hopefully around the UK
and kind of start to make a little bit of the dent
in this fish and chip shop industry.
Well, you said food is a powerful form of advocacy
and I think that's a good reminder
to pivot back to this conversation
that I wanted to have with you
around what constitutes effective advocacy.
And we need all different kinds of advocates.
We need extinction rebellion
and we need Peter and we need people like yourself,
like whatever its you and whatever feels correct
in your blueprint or your constitution
is needed in all forms, I think.
But I think there are core principles
around things at work and things that don't work.
And as somebody who's like out in the field,
talking to people all the time,
I mean, you alluded to it
and we've talked a little bit about it,
but not everybody has your level of skill and argumentation
or your linguistic abilities.
So for people who are trying to figure out
how to be effective advocates in their community,
whether it's veganism or environmentalism
or whatever it is that you're passionate about,
how do you counsel that person
so that they can be maximally effective
in what they're trying to do.
Yeah. It's a really good question.
You are absolutely right.
That we need so many different types of activism,
types of advocacy, because we're up against this,
I like to think of it as like a hydra,
like a multi-headed beast
and we need different types of advocacy
to take off all the different heads of this hydra.
And so it's important to not feel
like you have to do activism in a certain way,
but just find the voice that you have.
And I think apply the skills that you have
and things that you already enjoy into your advocacy,
because it's really important to be sustainable as well
and to not feel burn out by doing things that are grueling
and maybe contradict our passions in life.
So if you're an artist, you're a filmmaker,
you are a, a songwriter.
I think combining those passions with advocacy
is a really important thing.
But for me, I always say that the primary thing
that we should all do is take the time
to educate ourselves as vegans,
to the time to learn what people's oppositions are.
And we don't have to go too deep.
I mean, I have probably gone deeper
into these arguments than most people do,
and most people need to,
basically, I guess,
because I'm talking to so many different people
from different walks of life,
but I think primarily
you just need to find the main objections,
the main reasons that people have
and work out how to respond to those.
And I think that there are definitely ways of communicating
that are more effective than others.
And so it's about maybe taking the time
to reflect on before you were vegan,
how would you have responded?
And I always think this,
and I would love to sit down with myself seven years ago,
eight years ago, and how the conversations I have now,
but with myself back then,
and to see how I would've reacted.
I don't know how I would've reacted.
But what I do know is that communicating
in the way that I try to now
would've been more effective
than communicating in a more aggressive,
more judgemental way.
So I think trying to put yourself in that position
of the person you're speaking to and trying to reflect on
what would've worked for you,
and can that be translated into what will work for them
is a really important thing to do.
But the cornerstone to it is education
because education builds confidence.
I felt deeply uncomfortable at the beginning
because I was always worried
that someone was gonna say something
I didn't know how to respond to.
And I think a lot of my frustration
and my maybe anger at the beginning when I was advocating,
came, not from the person I was speaking to,
but from myself,
a frustration that I didn't know what to say,
a frustration that I didn't know how to respond,
that I was angry at myself for letting the animals down
because I didn't have this great rebuttal
to this one argument the person was using.
So the more I took the time to research,
the more to the time to learn
and the more practice I had,
the easier it got to be hopefully more level headed,
to be more empathetic,
to be more understanding of the personal viewpoint
the person has that I'm speaking to,
because I felt confident enough for my capabilities
to be able to address what they were saying.
I didn't feel worried about letting the animals down
or the movement down.
So I think it is about education and then practice.
Get used to having these conversations.
You could, even, if you have a vegan friend,
just have dummy conversations with them, practice,
I kind of what we did earlier.
You said, but Ed, what about this?
And I hopefully gave a good response.
And I think doing that's a really important thing to do
because it gets used to vocalizing your feelings,
vocalizing your beliefs.
Because it's one thing, knowing what you want to say,
and it's a different thing actually saying it.
So I think just practicing having that external vocalization
is also very important.
It's also the energy that you bring to the experience.
I mean, I think empathy and listening super important,
and just take your videos for example,
where you're in these conversations with people,
I think there's sort of an internet sensibility,
the like, oh, I'm gonna watch this person
own this other person or win this argument
or beat this person,
but that's not what's happening
if you're watching what you're doing closely,
like you're engaging this person
on their terms at their level, you're listening,
you're not interrupting.
You're trying to understand their perspective.
You're acknowledging them.
All of these things are critical, not just in advocacy,
but in human relations in general.
And I think we're also quick,
if there's frustrations
around that process of argumentation,
it's like I'm trying to win.
And it's like, if you can just let go of that
and be present for that other person
and try understand where they're coming from.
Not only will it sharpen your own ability to form arguments,
it will stress test your ideas and you'll get better.
But I think it's about letting go of the outcome of it
and just being available for the experience
that is super important.
It is.
I think fundamentally we all just want to be heard.
We all just want to want to listen to us
and take us seriously.
And there is this division,
this kind of binary that is more prevalent now
than probably it ever has been
where I think people just don't feel heard
where they feel maybe caricatured, stereotyped
and it's really damaging.
And so when I have these conversations,
I guess the first thing I want to do
is just make sure that the person knows
that I'm not trying to own them.
I'm not gonna put this video up vegan destroys-
(indistinct)
Exactly.
Which is again, why I take those first few minutes
at the beginning to build up a bit of a rapport.
So just let someone feel comfortable
knowing that's not my intentions.
And sometimes I'll say don't worry
that's not what we're here to do,
I just wanna polite conversation
because I think it's really important that people know that
so they can just let their defenses down.
And when I upload them, these are long format conversations.
It's not like some of the stuff you see on YouTube,
it's this chopped up stuff
where someone's made to look silly
and I'm not trying to you that.
I want people to be able to express themselves.
I want their arguments to be heard.
And I want my arguments in response to be heard.
And the powerful thing about making a video
is I'm thinking about the audience as well.
And having just two people sit down
and just rationally have a conversation
where they can shake hands at the end
and maybe agree to disagree, but still have that ending
means that the view who's watching
has been taken along
and they can create their own opinion
based on two opposing arguments.
How do they align?
What do they think?
I'm not under any false pretense
that the person who sits down with me is gonna leave saying,
"I'm gonna be vegan now."
It has happened. But more often than not,
that doesn't happen.
And I try and make the point to people.
And I've been saying it more recently
in the conversations I've just had which I'll be uploading
for the near future, I try and say to people at the end,
the reason that I'm here isn't to make you leave the table
saying you're gonna be vegan.
I'd love for that to be the case but I understand it's not.
It's for you to hopefully leave the table
with an more positive impression of veganism
than you had when you sat down.
And that's why I think optics are really important
because people don't often remember what they've heard,
they remember how that person made them feel.
We have arguments with people
and we can sometimes forget what the argument was about
or what the actual points were.
We can get bogged down and all that,
but we remember how they made us feel.
And so I want someone to leave that conversation,
having a positive feeling about it,
because they might then go
and think about these issues a bit more on their own,
because they feel comfortable and confident doing that
because I've made hopefully veganism
something they feel positively about.
That it isn't something that is attacking them,
that isn't something that's there to make them feel bad
to call them a murder or an abuser,
but it's instead just an interesting concept
that they actually probably align with.
And I think that feeling is often just as important
than the actual points that I made.
And that's why I try and construct
the conversations around that.
It's not about not holding people account either,
I think that's important.
You can hold people accountable and question them.
And in fact, the that by asking people questions
and by having a more respectful dialogue,
it allows you to ask questions
that you may not be able to ask.
It allows me to say things to people
that I might not have felt comfortable saying,
because we've built up an element of trust.
And they know that my intentions for saying those things
are not to try and get a click bait title
and not to try and make them seem silly,
that my intentions are because I think
this is an important point and I've built up enough trust,
hopefully that they don't feel attacked and threatened
when I say, "Do you think that's hypocritical,
or do you think that's in misalignment with your morals?
Or do you think that that's, immoral?"
These are a big questions and to try and to ask someone
if they're acting in an immoral way
is a big question to ask someone.
But if we can do so in a way
that is kind of created out of this respectful dialogue,
it makes that question a lot more palatable
for someone to hear and to actually go,
well, actually, yes,
I think it is immoral on what we do to animals.
But the important distinction being,
you're asking questions
rather than levying judgmental statements
at the other person.
And I think the more you engender that trust
and the manner in which the question is not only asked,
but formed so that you're not necessarily
coming at them directly,
like, do you think you're an immoral person,
but rather like, how does that decision make you feel
when you see this other thing or something.
There's ways of like getting around it
to have people stress test their own ideas
without coming at somebody from a judgemental stance.
And language is such an important part of that.
Sometimes I'll use words like you,
but I try and use words like we and us.
How do we feel about this?
Or do you think that it's wrong
when we do these things to animals?
I mean, I know that I'm not speaking about myself,
I'm not paying for some of these things to happen
in the same way,
but I think using we and us creates a sense of comradery.
It creates a sense of joint responsibility.
It doesn't make it about this individual person being bad.
It's about we as a collective are engaging in bad behaviors
and we as a collective have responsibility to work together.
So language is very important
and using different language techniques
and using questioning
and using different methods of communication
means that we can talk about really important issues
and really deep philosophical issues
and what could be very divisive issues,
but in a way that's actually constructive
and hopefully that happens.
I can't sit here and tell you
that it always works perfectly.
that I've had people who become upset,
angry that maybe don't leave feeling
as positive as I'd like them to, it happens,
but it's about minimizing how often that happens
and then reflecting on why it happened.
What did I say that caused that?
Could I have said something differently.
And everything is a kind of a process of trial and error.
'Cause we'll never be perfect.
But what we can do is I guess,
just strive to learn from our mistakes
and constantly better ourselves.
You seem like somebody
who knows how to set healthy boundaries.
You don't personalize any of this.
Like you're not letting it penetrate your psyche
if someone's disagreeing with you
and I think that's part of why you're good
at not getting too heated or reactive in these situations.
And I feel like a lot of people
who are sensitive, compassionate, people
who feel strongly about
whether it's veganism or some issue,
it's such an emotionally charged thing
and they can't create that distance
or that boundary between their emotional sensibility
and the advocacy, so it spills into it
and it actually ends up kind of corrupting
what they're trying to achieve.
I think what you've said is so important
and you're right.
I really try to detach myself
from what people are justifying.
If I was to sit there and think,
oh, this person's saying that plants feel pain,
therefore, their-
Yeah, we didn't talk about
the plants feel pain argument.
I mean, there's like 20 more arguments.
We could be here for like eight hours.
We could be. I heard the other day actually,
something very interesting, someone was saying-
Plant consciousness.
Yeah.
They said, what about thyme leaves and rosemary.
Now that's so it seems so arbitrary
that the line of conversation-
It's very specific.
So specific.
I think the point
was that we don't need to flavor our foods
and so rosemary, is it necessary for us to be healthy?
Exactly, so if rosemary can feel, then we should,
anyway, we've gone off this weird tangent,
as you can clearly tell from that point.
Well, so many of the arguments
live so far out on the margins as a way to justify behaviors
because when you hit the bullseye of it,
it doesn't make sense.
So we have to live in these weird artificial examples
that aren't really real life situations.
That's true. That's true.
And I have to say to people,
when they say about plants for pain,
I say, are you saying that cutting the stalk of a broccoli
is morally only the same
as cutting the throat of a pig or a cow.
Most people realize that that's not the same.
Some people will try and take me a little bit further
and they'll go, yeah, that's the same.
And if I was to think about that
and to think about what they're justifying,
it would then be a lot easier,
as you were saying just before,
to have that more emotional response.
And so there is this kind and I guess,
personal boundary setting,
there is this kind of detachment that I have
from thinking too deeply about it,
because it allows me to, again,
distance the person from the action.
Good people can do bad things
so I need to make sure that I'm creating that distinction.
They're justifying a bad thing,
but that doesn't make them a bad person.
These are all the reasons why they're justifying it.
Yes, their excuses may seem arbitrary, they are arbitrary.
Yes, they may seem nonsensical because they are
but at the same time,
I can understand that there is this mechanism
behind their thought process.
There is this social, cultural, personal experience
that is leading them to this moment
where they're now using this excuse.
And it's not because they're this tech terrible person
who relishes in animal violence.
It's, there's all of this baggage
that has brought us to that point
and having that understanding helps me just,
keep that distance from the truth
of what we're talking about.
To view it a little bit more intellectually,
to view it a little bit more as an abstraction
rather than to think about
this is what's happening right now
and this is what they're trying to justify.
That definitely helps.
So the book, "This Is Vegan Propaganda"
you did an amazing job this book.
Oh, thank you.
This is gonna be
a perennial bestseller.
You really,
knocked it out of the park, I think.
It follows somewhat the trajectory
that we spoke about today.
I mean, essentially you talk about your personal on-ramp
into this movement
and you address your general philosophy around veganism
and then you kind of take (indistinct)
us through all of the different implications
of animal agriculture from the philosophical
and compassionate arguments
to the environmental implications.
There's a whole section on pandemics and health, et cetera.
So I highly recommend everybody check it out.
It's extremely well crafted and I'm excited for you.
I'm nervous.
I wanted to write a book that people would feel confident
giving to like a non-vegan,
that kind of like touched on every argument
and hopefully made a good case
for all of the different reasons to be vegan.
But I also wanted to have those personal aspects to it.
But I'm nervous I think 'cause it is just me,
it's just my thoughts, my feelings,
it's such a personal thing to write,
because you of course will well know yourself
and making these Surge videos, it's collaboration,
having a restaurants collaboration, it's all collaboration.
And of course there's so many people
that have helped with the book
from the publishing house and such,
but having that real personal thing
that's gonna be out there for people to buy
and review and judge,
and I guess also importantly formulate their opinion
about veganism over, it's quite quite nerve-wracking.
I'm trying to remember
if there has been a book about veganism
that has approached it in this kind of comprehensive way
in recent memory.
I mean, it really is, when I gave you a blurb,
I made this comparison to Peter Singer,
I don't know how you feel about that,
but I do think there are parallels
like you are your generation's version of that.
Like you have decided to shoulder this mantle,
this responsibility and this book is a product
of everything that you've been talking about
in your videos for some time.
And it's done in a way where I think,
obviously it's gonna appeal to people who are vegan,
but it really is written with this sensibility
that it's not necessarily intended for those people.
It's really intended for the vegan person
who gives it to their friend or says,
"Maybe you should check this out."
And it it's very welcoming in that kind of tone and tenor.
Oh good. That's exactly what I wanted.
I wanted a book that was a book that vegans could read
and they would probably learn things
maybe they didn't already know about.
So it was a good tool for them to become better advocates,
but I always wanted it to be a book
that was for a non-vegan to read,
that was for that reluctant family member,
that skeptical friend,
or even just the curious person in the bookshop
and the point of the title I suppose, is to be grabbing,
to kind of be a little bit tongue and cheek.
So people kind of raise an eyebrow,
the cover it's quite bright, it's a bit different.
It has this kind of like kind of Soviet era.
Soviet era.
Yeah, exactly.
It's all propaganda.
All propaganda.
The whole thing.
Yeah, exactly.
Toss it in the garbage.
Exactly, it's not worth the paper its printed on.
But we really wanted to play with the idea
of it being this kind of propaganda piece
so that people could read it and go,
"Oh, this, these industries are calling propaganda.
Oh, okay, now I understand why they call it propaganda."
And everything's extensively referenced,
there are citations.
And I just wanted to kind of draw people's awareness
to the fact that when farmers are accusing
or when the industry are accusing vegans
of spreading propaganda,
they're not attacking vegans,
they're attacking the scientific literature,
they're attacking our moral compasses.
They're attacking something more objective
than this vegan bias
that can sometimes be perceived as existing.
And it's really an attack on so much more than just vegans.
And I think I want people to read the book
and hopefully reach the end and go,
"Okay, I understand that now,
I understand why they call it propaganda.
And potentially there is another side to this story."
And the way the book is structured,
having the first section about ethics and morals
is important to me because that's why I came into this
and is the most important thing for me.
But then having that section
that talks about the environment pandemics chronic health
to show the true enormity of it.
But then the final section is about the mechanism behind it.
Because as we've spoken about quite extensively today,
it's not just about having the understanding
of why it's bad,
it's about having the empowerment to understand
why we act in the way that we do
and how we can get through that.
And I think the first thing we have to acknowledge
is the barriers that are in place,
how our behaviors have been influenced,
why they've been influenced.
And through that, we can then put into practice,
changing our behaviors,
to align with all the reasons why we should.
And that's why it's stretched in that way
to end with that hopefully a sense of empowerment
about what we can achieve.
Well, it definitely comes across
and you should be very proud.
Thank you, Rich.
Ed, you're a powerful voice
and I have so much respect for the work that you do.
If I can ever be of service to you,
I think what you're doing is really important
and it's just been cool to spend a couple hours with you.
So thanks for doing it.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
It's great to connect and yet to pick your mind
and to have this conversation has been really wonderful.
And I appreciate your support with the book as well.
Yeah, absolutely man.
So everybody go pick up "This Is Vegan Propaganda".
Ed is easy to find on the internet.
He's @EarthlingEd pretty much everywhere,
but start on his YouTube page and go down the rabbit hole
of his many, how many videos do you have now?
And you got tons of stuff.
Oh, quite a lot.
And we try to create a variety of content as well,
but by the time this podcast goes up,
I'll probably have quite a lot more as well
I'm sure of that.
How often do you upload?
Not as often as I should,
but because I'm expanding the team,
getting an editor who's helping me out and stuff,
there'll be more consistent.
And the past few weeks I've got so many debates,
just trying to work our way through.
So should be a good healthier number of debates
on my channel by the time this goes up.
Good deal.
All right, man.
Well, come back and talk to me again sometime.
I'd like to.
Thanks, Rich
Thanks, buddy.
Peace.
Plants.
(upbeat music)